e
e e
time at the time being 10:05 I will open
the public hearing on HB
290 and first we have representative
string on introduce the bill uh thank
you very much uh uh I'm Jerry Stringham
I represent Lincoln Woodstock in Easton
in Grafton District 3 I'm a member of
the finance committee uh division 3 uh
but more importantly I'm a former member
and uh still heart heartfelt participant
in the Ways and Means Committee and uh
I'm delighted to be here for you and I'm
proud to introduce uh HB 290 increasing
the taxes on cigarettes and electronic
cigarettes and establishing a committee
to study taxes on Tobacco and other
nicotine
products uh thank you for uh this
opportunity to address the most valuable
and important deliberative body in the
New Hampshire legislature that being the
Ways and Means Committee
um wh while HB 290 is a tax bill I view
this first as a public health Bill uh
nicotine use and addictions robs our
citizens of actual years and quality
years of life uh the side effects of
nicotine consumption cost our society
funds to treat diseases that would not
otherwise be
present and taxpayers insurers expense
uh for these things smoking and vaping
are legal activities that nonetheless
the public has an interest in
encouraging the free choice to use less
uh secondhand smoke itself also has
devastating Health consequences even to
non-users
reducing the free practice of nicotine
use comes in three buckets which I
plagiarize uh from Nancy vaugh of the
American Heart Association from past
testimony before this committee those
are regulation Taxation and
cessation uh this bill uh just deals
with
taxation HB 290 deals with three
separate subjects cigarettes vaping e
cigarettes and then finally other
categories of nicotine and tobacco use
so let's talk about cigarettes first New
Hampshire cigarette taxes are the lowest
in the New England region uh this bill
proposes to raise the cigarette tax by a
dollar a pack from $1.78 to
278 unlike most taxes the cigarette
taxes do not auto adjust with inflation
as do most taxes that Granite Staters
pay for example like the meals and rooms
tax uh for example uh 15 years ago you
might you might have bought a tuna fish
sandwich at a restaurant for $4 uh you
would have paid uh 9% of that $4 in tax
or
36 today the price might be $8 and then
the tax would have gone up from 36 Cents
to now it would be 66 cents for a tuna
fish sandwich without the legislature
doing anything because it's a percent
tax uh the taxes that we pay on
cigarettes have fixed at a $1.78 they
haven't changed uh in any way since uh
2013 uh they were actually this the
cigarette tax was actually reduced
during the Great
Recession uh in 2011 by 10 cents a pack
uh but returned uh to the
$178 uh level that had been in place uh
for 6 years before that automatically
because the promised extra Revenue that
would come from having a low lower tax
rate never
materialized and uh part of the bill was
just saying if we didn't get more
revenue from cigarette taxes then the
rate would go back to a
$1.78 so since then uh since 2013
they've been at
a178 it should be noted that New
Hampshire's cigarette tax rate will
still be lower even with the added
dollar than all New England State's uh
present tax rate with the exception of
Maine uh Maine's current tax rate is $2
a pack uh but the main Governor um is is
has proposed and I I uh Pro I'll provide
a su summary of a press release on that
is proposing to increase their cigarette
tax by a dollar per pack bringing it up
to $3 per pack uh main cigarette uh
purchases are also subject to a 5% sales
tax so uh and uh the other states that
surround us are far higher so uh uh for
example if you're if you're over in hand
over uh even even uh the the tax rate
across border over in Vermont would be
over a dollar higher some states are
above $5 a
pack uh as a public health matter and
given the long Hiatus since the last
cigarette tax change uh HB 290 proposes
this change at this time so second let's
talk about vaping prior to
2019 vaping was legal and unregulated
and untaxed for that matter so as I said
there's regulation Taxation and cation
as three ways to handle that back in
2019 uh we were in a Child Health crisis
caused by the proliferation of this new
form of of nicotine use kids were being
addicted at an alarming rate and 5 years
later we now know know that a generation
of kids have become addicted to nicotine
with permanent negative effects uh with
a sense of urgency the house passed uh
what was Bill that started in the Senate
uh the tax rates were considered by this
great committee but were put in place
with the explicit understanding they
were a
placeholder and uh the same the the same
rates were assigned that was in the SE
the Senate bill that first regulated
vaping the rates itself were not heavily
vetted by this committee uh in fact I
believe they were proposed by industry
itself uh there was some concern in the
committee to not adopt the bill because
once the rates were established they
would not be able to be increased easily
as there's always a substantial group uh
of concerned uh legislators that vote
against anything that sounds like a tax
increase even if the original tax rate
for example 8% less than attack some of
a tuna fish sandwich was meant to be a
placeholder as an individual cherishes
the role of businesses and shaping a
quality life I I am heart sick at the
business practices of a leading closed
Vape vaping system the business
practices of this one manufacturer a a
leader in the space were reprehensible
uh I have a link to an episode of the TV
show called American Greed that uh
discusses um uh the practice is about a
7-minute overview um that I would
encourage you to watch if you want to
and I'll I'll provide it to Karen uh to
forward to the
committee but I would also like to say
that even though this manufacturer's uh
Behavior was against the public interest
I believe there are many manufacturers
of oping vaping systems that are very
responsible and work with their
customers to reduce nicotine consumption
over time and use their platform to do
so so it's not not a um uh a single type
of industry but uh others have discussed
it the ways and means briefing part of
the movement from cigarettes to vaping
is also due to a lower tax burden on
vaping uh for consumers than for
cigarettes another reason to reopen and
reconsider the appropriate uh tax rate
uh and perhaps replace the the uh
placeholder rates that were put in place
with the original legislation in 1990
and 20
so the proposal is to move all of the
levels for Vaping um uh New Hampshire is
unusual in that we have uh two different
um uh vaping tax rates almost every
state bases it on one formula or another
um and a few States still do not tax
vaping products at
all so um and finally the leg this
legislation calls for a legislative
committee to review all tobacco and
nicotine regulation and tax rates I
think it's a it makes great sense for
this great committee to look at all
these other tobacco rates and for for
example even premium cigars which are
untaxed at this point and should do so
as a matter of of practice every every
bium overall this legislation would
raise a significant amount of money for
the state I think the timing for this
might be more acceptable uh uh at this
point uh that's because we just
eliminated the IND tax and uh uh for
this bium without any offsetting uh
Revenue increases or expense reductions
and this is one way to maybe fill in
some of the Gap uh that am amount is
extremely large this this won't fill
that by itself but it would help um
nicotine taxes are definitely less
harmful than other forms of taxes that
we have in terms of the economy so I
would consider a nice effort uh to move
towards the balanced budget uh despite
the unfund funded tax cuts the last
legislature left us with and I think
this committee is the only place in New
Hampshire that has the skills and
experience and expertise to figure it
out so I'm pleased to offer this uh to
you um with the hope that uh uh that can
make a better state for us so with that
I'll I'll take any questions that you
may have thank you for your testimony
representative Ro
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
representative taken this question I
really have two questions uh do you have
an idea of how the 278 you propose
compares to the current in real dollars
when um the doar 78 was first
established oh or enacted so uh yeah so
if you 278 would be pretty almost
exactly the same as a178
was in real dollars when it was first
put in in 2008 put another way the rate
of inflation since 2008 is about
56% and 278 is about 50 cents or 56%
higher than
a178 so
basically uh in real dollars the tax
rate for cigarettes would be unchanged
so if it was handled the same way that
say some of our percentage taxes are
handled they probably would adjust it to
to about that rate a followup Mr
chairman on that position you're taking
uh do you consider raising the cigarette
tax over several year did you did you
consider raising that over several years
rather than by a dollar just here all at
once oh that's a really good question um
the uh so you know one thing one thing
that this committee could recommend or
the bill could recommend is raising the
tax say 20 cents a year by or uh over 5
years uh but um in terms of having a
public health impact it's much better
actually leave it flat for a number of
years and then raise it by a lot and
because people notice the price
difference and allows them to
consider use that as an excuse to
consider a cation program or quitting
smoking if you just raise it a little
bit every year the system will kind of
filter it in and they really won't even
notice the change in the tobacco prices
that much so you know the analogy to me
is like the frog and the boiling water
you know you turn it up slowly they
don't notice it's getting hotter and
hotter but if you know if they jump into
the 150 degree water they say you know I
got to get the heck out of this thing so
I got to stop smoking so you know as a
matter of public health policy If part
of the goal is to um encourage people to
think about whether they want to smoke
and perhaps um you know stop using
nicotine then um you know a periodic
dramatic increase in rates and then
keeping it level for several years will
do better to do that Mr chair my second
question concerns vaping tax uh how do
you how do New Hampshire tax rates
compare to the other states
concerning vaping tax yeah so even with
the proposed rate that's in here um uh
again we would still be equal to or less
than all the states in New England
except for for Maine we're now way way
below all the other states at the
current rate and as I said you know the
the portion of it that's 8% you know we
have this bifurcated tax system that's
in um uh as described in um chapter 78
uh 2
um and uh so you know just reading from
that the the um
um the rate is 30 30 cents per
milliliter of volume of liquid of uh or
other substance in the cartridge
container um uh and uh for one and then
uh for for containers of liquid or of
other substances containing nicotine
that are intended to be opened uh so an
open container system it's 8% of the
wholesale price so um and you know more
typically you know the the the rate
proposed here which was uh um given
given as a suggestion to me by the
American Heart Association is equivalent
to the 65% of wholesale price that we
use for other systems so so thank you
for that as far as vaping taxes by state
I'll also provide a link uh that comes
from the tax Foundation that lists The
Vaping taxes in 2024 for all states and
I'll provide that to Karen okay
representative Omen yeah thank you I had
a question on the primary purpose of the
bill you know where the revenue
committee here Ways and Means so is the
primary purpose of the bill to raise
revenue with the reduced smoking is an
incidental Factor the primary purpose of
the bill to cut back on the nicotine
tobacco stock
with uh Revenue raising being a
secondary
issue well I I personally think one of
the great things about this committee is
that they can think about both and um
you know I I I watch the uh
presentations to Ways and Means and and
uh even some of the speakers that I
didn't necessarily agree with you know
talked about that some taxes do more
harm than others uh in fact uh propos
suggested that um uh that um property
taxes do less harm than than income
taxes and so I think this committee is a
logical place uh to consider that uh in
this case
um uh you know I can I I consider it
both I think you know this is a uh a
bill that increases uh Revenue um mainly
because it's not going to be be
successful in in
um uh uh having so many people quit
using nicotine that that the the overall
rate of consumption will drop enough for
it to go down but if people chose not to
use nicotine and the revenue uh didn't
materialize I'd consider it a successful
Bill and um uh so if it uh so I I I
really think think it it tries to do
both but I see it as a public health
bill first uh and first and foremost but
thank you very much for your question so
um can you tell us why one tax or I
don't know if you if you're aware why
one tax is eight% the other tax was 30%
do you know what the reasoning behind
that
was
um well there there's a matter of I you
know you
one of the issues and I I said we didn't
we didn't um spend a we we acted a
pretty short order on this but the clo
systems they sell a piece of Hardware
that that's got a fixed amount of uh
nicotine and and um uh material in it uh
the open systems are meant to be reused
they might have nicotine with different
different levels of nicotine especially
for those who are trying to wean people
off nicotine they may have a higher
level at first and then with their
follow-up uh fillings might have less
and um uh so you know it's issues about
taxing the hardware versus uh the
nicotine itself and um uh and uh I think
there was a lot of uh persuasive cases
being made you know for those who were
pursuing a quasi medical use of it even
though didn't have a medical label um
that the systems might be different so I
I was just concerned that because one
was 8% one was 30% you're raising them
both to 30 cents yeah what did I say 30
cents per millit 30 cents and one was
eight 8% they're very very different
structures and we're one of we're pretty
much the only state that has that kind
of a bifurcation of these two different
types of systems except from I think
Arkansas thank you yes represent thank
you Mr chair thank you representative
for taking my question uh what what do
you think
uh what is your vision for what the
committee that you're proposing will do
that this
bill won't do if we if we uh accept it
and pass
it because you if I may you you you've
done a lot of work here follow on
research on this so what what's left for
the committee to do
thank you yeah um well you know I think
the the cigarettes the cigarette tax is
a little clearer that's been been in
place a lot longer uh I I heard some
testimony at uh or speech last week uh
uh from one of the Senators talking
about how some of the vaping systems are
uh avoiding taxation at all so there may
be some regulation issues that over
overlay um but you know I I I I think
the
um
um the the interweaving of you know what
what's you know New Hampshire being a
being a place uh where free access to
things like this at a reasonable tax
rate should be considered I do think
there's considerable up upward room with
still having um still maintaining our
lowest in the region or uh uh tax rates
so I would I would expect uh that the
committee would want to verify that and
and and talk about really what what what
the reasonable
um uh tax level should be for these
things thank you represent ORS thank you
Mr chair thanks rep for taking my
question so I'm glad rep M asked the
question about whether it's to raise
revenue or kill tobacco or whatever but
it looks like we're trying to raise
revenue
that's the way this looks to me so a
couple comments before I ask my question
one would be we've already heard about
the premium cigars in the state of New
Hampshire we don't want to drive that
industry out you know if we were to tax
that we would we saw what happened in
Massachusetts but my other thought was
like menthol cigarettes as the states
around us have killed off menthol
cigarettes I mean it's added to our
industry and I would hate to see our
state lose all that revenue from the
other states so I think maybe one thing
you might consider if you want to raise
revenue with this bill and I talked to
one of the other reps uh yesterday about
this was maybe you would just raise at
22 cents so we don't exceed I think it's
Maine is at $2 a
pack so I I believe it's Maine in any
event we don't want to exceed what our
neighbors are doing we want to keep that
Advantage because we have people coming
in from state so would you agree with
that that we want to we don't want to
lose that revenue or well uh first first
of all I you know I will provide this uh
that Maine is proposing to increase to
$3 a pack uh so I certainly think that's
fair um consideration is what is the
competitive impact and um you know I I
would guess uh um um my my good friend
from uh from Greenland there he's
probably the closest to Maine so maybe
some of the of of the members of this
committee most of you are over on the
Vermont border uh but uh but spread
around um but um uh so some of the
businesses might there might be
concerned uh but Maine also does pay
sales tax on top of it so they really
pay 225 in state tax not
$2 uh but then that'll go up to 330 uh
if if the proposal goes in in a dollar
here
uh would um uh would still have us have
the lowest rate in the region I I think
that's an entirely reasonable line of
inquiry to consider um uh you know being
the lowest in the region and what that
may do for businesses versus the public
health impact um but I think I think um
I I also think if main knows that uh
we're considering the similar uh tax
increase that would encourage them to do
the same thing as well so thank
you representative D thank you Mr
chairman I thank my friend from Lincoln
for taking my question and it kind of
couples with what representative ORS
just said I don't happen to be on the
Vermont nor main border I'm on the
Massachusetts border we reap a lot of
revenue from cigarette and vape taxes I
see it daily M commuters come in
by the product in New Hampshire because
we tax it right we do it right they go
home they leave the revenue with us I'm
just wondering because I know you do
your due
diligence what may be the impact
negatively if we raise the tax on this
we're counting on this Revenue right now
and everyone agrees we have to find uh
places to uh both increase revenue and
tighten our belts I'm afraid of exposure
in the revenue we're already counting on
and I'm a a former smoker myself so I I
get the health aspect of it too but um
we do things right in New Hampshire they
you know we're making those sales for a
specific reason New Hampshire Advantage
is real
and tary a secondary question is I'm
more specific to the tobacco tax you
said a a acceptable rate
how did you come up with the
$1 per and I thank you for taking my
question well it's always nice to get a
question from a from a reformed smoker
from Salem because
uh the um uh the the the dollar actually
was was meant to be um sufficiently
enough so that smokers would notice the
difference and um I I think there's
there's a tradeoff between um you know I
had um a good question from my friend
about raising taxes slowly versus
raising them all at once um the you know
there you know clearly will be tobacco
products offered in New Hampshire that
are not offered in Massachusetts due to
regulation basically the Menthol
products their tax rates even with the
full dollar will still be significantly
less than they are in
Massachusetts so um you know those those
on their way uh to go skiing in Lincoln
certainly would would find it valuable
um to stock up while they're here even
at
278 um uh but the um uh the full dollar
and doing it all at once was was you
know really meant for for those in state
who smoke and just to have them consider
it
so thank you Mr chairman thank you I I
have a differing perspective and I've
heard the the health issue brought up
and just again the health issue my
problem with that
is I want everybody to have the freedom
if if you want to chain smoke cigarettes
that's your business the business of
this committee is uh revenue and
Taxation I think we need to stick with
that and and uh that that's where the
hard cell has to be for me I smoked for
over 40 years it was my decision to do
what I did I don't want this to to be
used as a vehicle to get people to quit
smoking it may end up being a vehicle to
help people quit smoking but that's not
and this is not this is not a cation
program this is um uh and um it 100%
relies on free choice of granite sters
to choose whether to smoke or not
whether to vape or not so um but there
is a public cost um Health cost and and
that to treat people and this raises
more money that way uh to do that and I
think I think in a way that's more in
the state interest than for example
taxing um business income or something
else so um but thank you very much for
your questions and
comments representa
Aly oh
still I only look that way
representative Southworth thank you for
taking my question um I missed it at the
beginning what is the current rate in
Massachusetts you
know
350 so we still would be well below
Massachusetts we still would have the
menthal and I might have missed it but
actually your bill doesn't mention
reducing the number of smokers I don't
think
so really it is purely a revenue bill
that was just kind of your aside um
because that's really the part we have
to decide about is the revenue
part and also um would you think that
all of these are gradually be going up
anyway for all of New England over time
again so it does keep up with uh you
know so you don't freeze them for 10
years like they did before yeah my
understanding is Massachusetts is
considering raising them right now and
anyway so I mean I think it will go like
this as far as the different states um
but um I'm comfortable with the 278 it
is 278 is what the build is thank
you you have a question representative
Aly yes
um I'm intrigued by what you were saying
about working on the the uh Vape costs
and this committee spent a lot of
time uh
bipartisanly figuring and led by a brami
figuring out uh what we thought was a
fair price for the open we we did that
open canister versus the
closed basically
because the liquid in the open canister
is the only thing that people keep
buying if they've
got if they've got a device already that
will take it
um and we send it over to the Senate and
the Senate I think cut it by about four
or maybe
more and we're stuck with that
rate right now and
so it the other thing that we had
considered a little bit was um
the the interests of the very small uh
traders in in the open canisters who
were more of a craft group than than a
retailer and um trying to protect them
to some at some extent but now uh what
we're hearing is that it's all
um most of what is bought is brought in
illegally from
China without any control over what's in
it without any uh on tax being imposed
on it and um there is a bill in the
Senate that I'm on that is working
towards a solution to to handling the
tax issue at anyway but
um I find it sort of difficult talking
about both of them at the same time the
the cigarette and
the and the
vaping but you have a question for him
and so I'm what it sounded like you
had
uh you had information from the senate
about why they decided to cut
everything and
did you well the Ju Just What I heard is
that's what the industry the industry
suggested is what I had heard it
happened at the time and it came back we
had to either leave leave uh vaping
unregulated or accept the rates as
placeholders and and uh that's how we
got where we
are so would that then have been the
small industry that we were also trying
to protect because they were trying to
cut people down at least that's it what
they were saying well I know or what my
sympathies were more for those people
but I'm not I'm not sure where the
Senate was based on what I've heard the
jewels right the
jewels thanks thank you question I have
a um a lot of pin cards here with people
who want to speak so does anyone have
final question for representative
Stringham
okay seeing none thank you very
much all right I've got um I believe
I've got about 10 pink cards here if I
counted correctly um I would ask that um
we try to keep uh I know some of you
have written different times some of you
didn't say how much time you have to
speak um let's try to keep it to three
minutes and
um and if and if you're hearing
something please don't repeat so we can
get through this uh as efficiently as
possible all right so next up is Nancy
V guess I'm on already oh good good
morning esteemed members of the House
Ways and Means Committee um for the
record I am Nancy vaugh government
relations director for the American
Heart Association
um I am dedicated to the uh the state of
New Hampshire on my work um and uh
Tobacco Control is just one policy issue
that um that we work on in order to um
increase the health for all citizens um
I do have testimony which I suppose I
should have passed around before because
I'm going to make reference to something
in here that you might want to be able
to see so I will do that excuse me
um the American Heart Association is in
support of um House Bill 290 um we very
much appreciate um representative
Stringham for bringing this bill forward
and starting the discussion um which has
not been had here in in New Hampshire
for quite some time about raising um
tobacco taxes um and uh so we very much
in support of a minimum of $1 um per
pack for uh tax on cigarettes if um any
anyone wanted to go higher than that we
would also support that um and also that
we do feel we need to bring the rate for
the ecigarette um tax um up um so that
it is in parody with the tobacco um that
the the cigarette um tax rate um and we
are using um um in our in our discussion
that we've had so far using the rate for
other tobacco products refer to it as
OTP um which are non-combustible
products that um are popular amongst
youth um and and adult smokers as well
um that they might be doing in addition
to their um their um their smoking um
heart disease and so um are the some of
the leading causes of um death and
disability and health care costs in in
the whole country as as well as in New
Hampshire and tobacco is the leading
preventable cause of um heart disease
cardiovascular diseases um so that is
why we're here today um we are here
because there is a health benefit to
raising tobacco taxes high enough so
that the price is felt um by the
consumer um for um really for those
folks who um are considering um stopping
their tobacco use um a price increas
um could help um support their efforts
in doing
that um there's a three-fold benefit
though to raising tobacco taxes besides
reducing and preventing tobacco related
um diseases and um and uh the the use of
tobacco it also creates a stable source
of revenue for states um you will see
attached um to my testimony um a listing
of all the states who have raised their
tobacco cigarette taxes um by um at
least $1 per pack and you will see that
despite the fact that the the the um the
number of packs sold will go down in
states that increase their tobacco tax
by a meaningful um level um that they
always see a revenue increase um and
you'll you'll hear from from others um
that will follow me um regarding um what
um what the impact for New Hampshire
could be on revenues and you are a
revenue committee so I understand that
that is really what you will all be
looking at um but I appreciate all of
your concern for the public health
impact as well um so again um whenever a
state increases their tobacco cigarette
tax um by a meaningful amount they will
see an increase in tax revenues most
adult smokers getting back to the the
health aspect most adult smokers begin
before the age of 18 and so um young
people and lowincome folks are very
price sensitive so again that is is why
we we look at a tobacco tax rate for the
the public health
benefits we are looking at the $1 per
pack in New Hampshire in particular
because what we do see again evidence
shows that every 10% increase in the
price of a pack of cigarettes results in
a decrease in people stopping um using
uh cigarettes so for adults it's a
little bit less a little bit higher for
young people and the um the price
average price of a pack of cigarettes um
is is close to uh to $10 with all the
taxes included on it um so that does
correspond to a 10% increase in price if
I know um representative um Stringham
was asked this this question and he he
did um answer it and we we support the
answer that he gave which is if you were
to do lower increases over a a longer
period of time um we will not see that
um that public health benefit um there
are many ways that the tobacco price at
the registers could drop um and uh and
they consumer would not see any any
difference in their price of um of
cigarettes um and again as I said the um
the tax rate on ecigarettes which are
very popular with youth um the the
cigarette smoking rate amongst young
people in New Hampshire is now under 4%
which is fabulous news but they are
using um ecigarettes at at an increasing
rate um and other tobacco products that
are constantly coming on the market so
we always need to be mindful of that
there hasn't been a lot of of time or um
or energy um nationally to um look at
the decrease um in use with a a tax on
ecigarettes so this is something that I
would urge a study committee on this if
if this bill is passed um to to look at
as well um and um the health care costs
so someone had referred to um tobacco
use as being something that only impacts
the tobacco user um we're talking
hundreds of millions of dollars in
health care costs in New Hampshire um
and and a a large almost 20% of that is
covered or or carried by the Medicaid um
uh program um and so the increase um in
taxes that spreads out to all taxpayers
is about $800 a year that people pay in
increase taxes for the cost of tobacco
related illness so it is something that
impacts everyone all
taxpayers um and I do have information
about that in my in my test
testimony um and again
so
um it Bears repeating so I'm sorry to be
repeating myself but um tobacco use
rates are decreasing
naturally whether it's policy in New
Hampshire policy in our neighboring
states we are seeing um uh usage rates
drop if we do not in New Hampshire raise
the
price raise the cigarette tax we will
continue to see a decrease in revenues
and I'm hoping that that this does pass
and that we do see this increase in
revenues from the tax increase to help
offset some other gaps that might be
seen in New Hampshire's revenues
currently so that's one thing that I
would would suggest is something that
you can look at with this bill is to you
know look at it consider it and see what
um what the other gaps are and revenues
that this might be able to help fill and
again um it is proven um amongst these
other states that you see in my other
attachment to increase revenues um no
matter what the um what what goes on
with the sale the number of of packs
sold in the
state um and so I thank you I hope that
you'll consider my testimony um and if
you have questions I will attempt to
answer them
representative thank you for taking my
question you just uh testified that
whenever there's an increase in the tax
there's an increase in Revenue yes and
at the same time there's a decrease in
people purchasing it even though there's
increase in Revenue so how does there a
correlation between health benefit tax
increase because the the decrease in the
sales of tobacco products is typically
because people are not using as much
tobacco as they were before so again
what we actually do want to see decrease
in the number of packs of cigarettes
sold but you as a state as a Ways and
Means Committee will see the revenue
from that tax increase higher and will
more than cover the um the loss of sales
in
pxs I'm
sorry yes represent
opal thank you Mr chairman and and I
apologize I was testifying before
another committee so apologize for
coming in late but um
I have two questions if I may um first
to
clarify did I understand you correctly
to say that it the the impact of the
health uh the detrimental health effects
of tobacco smoking use of tobacco
products generally is creating an $800
additional cost per New Hampshire
resident because of the impact on
Medicaid I I believe this might actually
be more naal numbers but yes and and we
are seeing the same Trend in in all
states in terms of tobac related illness
and Medicaid do you if if I may follow
up Mr ch um do you have or or might you
be able to obtain uh information
regarding the number of uh deaths
related strictly to Tobacco uh you know
whether it's lung cancer or or throat
cancer you know all of the various
cancers um I frankly I ask as somebody
who I started smoking when I was 16 um
and um fortunately I I quit at 44 uh two
weeks before I had open heart surgery um
directly related to smoking
congratulation on the quitting and
congratulation on successfully getting
through your surgery um and um so yes
actually um a a partner of mine um
behind me also signed to testify and he
has that um that information for you so
um I I I would get it for you but I
think he has it for you and if he does
not we're happy to continue looking into
it I think I saw him nodding in the
back thank you Mr
chair okay thank you for your testimony
thank you very
much next I have Harry Sha
I know good morning Comm commune members
my name is Harry Shaw I am the uh
operations manager for eastwest
Distributors uh we are a tobacco
wholesaler on the uh Sea Coast in sebr
um we distribute to New Hampshire and uh
main customers uh our main customer base
is New
Hampshire um we have quite a few
customers I just wanted to come to let
you know that
within our customer base most of our
customers are on the uh the border of
Massachusetts and Vermont um some of our
best customers and uh I've heard
countless times from them calling us and
say hey I have a special order I got
someone coming from Massachusetts I got
someone coming from a different state to
to they need a special order can you
bring it to us and it brings these
people up from these other states for
this Revenue I feel if we we do raise
this we're going to lose out on this
Revenue that we're we're we're getting
we're getting New York we're getting
Rhode Island we're getting Vermont we're
getting Massachusetts customers coming
up and spending their money and we're
collecting this this tax revenue I feel
by by raising it before these other
states do we're risking that of losing
that customer you know
it's it's it's something we see um that
Revenue has increased for us because of
these um customers that we've taken on
we we used to have just local customers
and then we went to the Vermont border
and we see that quite a few customers in
in on the Vermont border um have people
come over as well so it's it's not just
the Massachusetts we do have it happen
on both sides of the state you know not
so much in Maine because they are fairly
close to us but if we do jump up you
know we may lose some customers in New
Hampshire might go over to main you know
on on that border so um that's just
where we're at can I answer any
questions thank you um do you do
anything with vaping products or okay
representative ORS thank you Mr chair
thanks for taking my question so how
much of an increase do you think your
business can handle before you start to
see a negative
impact um in other words my concern is
going more than 22 cents a pack on the
tax if it does go up 22 cents puts us
right where Maine is now I agree so do
you think that would be a maximum do you
think there's a different maximum that
you would go to I I feel like that would
be a safe spot for us to feel that we
wouldn't lose those customers I feel
we're we're keeping those customers
they're not going up to main the ones
that are coming from other states I feel
like if we we do that a lot of these
customers for them to drive an extra you
know a a lot of our customers are in the
the Salem the seabook area um that for
them to go another you know five miles
up the coast is really nothing for these
people that are coming from New York
they're coming from Rhode irland and you
know other parts of Massachusetts I
really don't think it would be that big
of a deal if we were you know 78 cents
that 80 cents you know you're talking $8
a carton a lot of these people come up
they buy five six cartons at a time so
they they they come up once a month
they're spending a great you know great
deal amount of money with these with
these customers these are you know
things we're hearing from these
customers and I feel like we would lose
that that that sale so followup followup
so yeah I had the same thought that you
mentioned in terms of let the other
states raise their taxes and then we can
raise ours behind them would you I I
take it you do agree with that
absolutely absolutely very good thank
you okay seeing no more questions thank
you very much thank you for time
uh next I have uh Michael
Rolo good morning Mr chairman members of
the committee for the record my name is
Michael Rolo I'm the director of
government relations for the American
Cancer Society cancer Action Network
here in New Hampshire and I have the
pleasure of covering in the state of
Vermont now too so te a little bit of
what's going on over
there my home is New Hampshire um and we
are in support of here appearing today
in support of House Bill 290 and thank
representative Stringham for bringing it
forward so we can have this conversation
I apologize if I did not bring my
glasses so I'm kind of a bit of a
disadvantage but I'm going do my best um
there are um you've already heard about
the number of public health benefits
from from miss vau the Heart Association
the Cancer Society would um would only
Echo what she's saying so I'm not going
to repeat myself I know you have a lot
of other folks that want to speak today
but there are approximately
10,290 Grand estator that will be
diagnosed with cancer in
2025 and
unfortunately there are approximately
2,980 people
in the state of New Hampshire that will
lose their battle to
cancer the question was asked um ree by
of the previous speaker what um do we
know that the number the percentage of
of those deaths that may be attributable
to uh to tobacco use I can't speak to
heart disease um and all that goes along
with with what goes along with that but
I can tell you for cancer approximately
30.6 % of all deaths cancer deaths in
the state of New Hampshire are directly
attributable to tobacco use that would
correlate to approximately 9911
people out of the out of the estimate
that that will will lose their battle
this year with
cancer um but this is a revenue
committee so let's talk about the
economics of uh of this
bill the state of New Hampshire you've
already heard um incurs approximately
800 $47 million on Direct health care
cost directly related to tobacco use 847
million including
149.6 million in direct Medicaid cost to
the state of New Hampshire these are New
Hampshire numbers
847 and of that 140 almost 150 million
in Medicaid costs and additionally a
number that's even more sobering is the
state experiences approximately 1.5
billion that's with a B billion dollars
in loss productivity
due to smoking related um
illnesses that's a lot of
money but there is some good news if you
look at the other um the other handout
and before we get to the other handout
the question was asked by uh to a
previous couple previous speakers well
what if we just did it
incrementally we share the same concerns
at the Cancer Society that the Heart
Association does about the public health
impact but not just that if you did it
incrementally the tobacco industry is
very good at offsetting any kind of tax
increase or price increases with uh
practices they use uh with discounts and
payments to retailers and wholesalers
they've done this for for for years this
is not a new practice so anything less
than what's being proposed on House Bill
290 will be easily offset and
manipulated by these by these
companies so if you look at the second
handout we haven't talked about revenues
at all really this morning and what we
think this bill will bring in the uh
the fiscal note according to uh Dr or
Revenue rather was a little interesting
to me but we've been running Revenue
estimates for this committee I actually
do it in every state but for this
committee I've been working for the
Cancer Society for 14 years and I can
tell you every time we talk about
tobacco tax increases and it predates me
we run Revenue estimates for you
representative Aly and representative
major uh your predecessor Mr chairman
could probably tell you that we're we're
pretty good at estimating what we think
these taxes will bring in we were just
about spot on we were a little under uh
when we talked about the reduction and
how bad that was going to be for the New
Hampshire economy we lost a lot of money
so we have a pretty good track record
and according to our our estimates State
of New Hampshire is looking at if you do
a dollar increase $4
49.7 million almost $50 million an
additional Revenue through this uh this
tax increase but there are also uh
offsets um projected health savings you
can see on here and again I'm sorry I
didn't bring my classes so uh the
substantial amounts of money that um
that are uh potential savings over the
course of a number of years to to the
Health Care system and directly to the
state and Medicaid savings so I would
say that this is a
um a a good thing for the State of New
Hampshire we've talked about a little
bit about our neighbors uh to the south
east and west the Commonwealth of
Massachusetts charges $351
tobacco tax Vermont is
$38 Maine is $2 currently and we've
heard that Governor Mills has proposed a
dollar increase there but what you
haven't really heard a lot I mean
representative Stringham did mention
this but people were paying their state
sales taxes on top of this so um these
are uh the 35138 and $2 are not actually
the full fright of what people were
paying on top of the base price of their
tobacco products so uh New Hampshire
would still be lower of course we
wouldn't be as low as Maine um and I can
tell you I spent uh how many years 12
years sitting in the House of
Representatives as a member and um I
represented a border of community I
represented first my hometown of
Rollinsford and then the city of
summersworth in Rollinsford we had a lot
of tobacco retailers corner stores and
all of that and um they're all still
there they haven't stopped every time
there's a tobacco tax increase you'll
have people parade in here and tell you
that the stores every store in the
state's going to close but you will see
that there have been increases in
retailers across the state um so I
wouldn't be put off by that there are
real Public Health increases and impacts
and there are real Revenue positive
Revenue impacts that can be made by
passing this legislation with that Mr
chairman I'm going to stop and I'll be
happy to answer any
questions if I can thank you for your
testimony do I have any
questions seeing none thank you very
much thank
you uh so next I have
David SLI sfco okay thank you
micone good morning I'm David slka for
the
record
um thank you for the opportunity to
speak against HB
290 uh a bill that would increase the
tax burden on thousands of consumers and
businesses and roll out a well estab
established policy that is working for
New Hampshire can I stop you for a
minute what uh I think you say
representing NCP uh
NCD National convenience Distributors
okay
sorry yes so National convenience
Distributors that employ about thousand
you know hundreds of people that live
and touch New Hampshire daily our
company serves thousands of stores
across all six New England states
includes hundreds of retail locations in
New Hampshire with food sundies and
tobacco
products because all the tobacco
products must be stamped and distributed
through licensed wholesalers like my
company NCD
I um I have a unique perspective on how
tax policy affects behavior and and
purchases our experience has proven that
tax increases in New England of a dollar
or more a pack result in volume uh
decline of more than 21% of consumers
shift their purchasing behaviors to seek
Alternatives including price and
convenience today New Hampshire
retailers and consumers alike enjoy the
price Advantage which has resulted in
significant volume growth in New
Hampshire stores resulting in larger tax
revenue uh this comes at the expense of
our neighbors like the south east and
west and north in short it's a zero sum
game which someone wins and someone
loses uh cigarettes and evap products
Drive foot traffic into stores where the
purchase non-tobacco items like fresh
food beer gas and Lottery All benefit
the state of New Hampshire
so I strongly hope you oppose the dollar
increase on cigarettes and keep New
Hampshire businesses
whole thank you thank you any
questions no yes represent ORS thank you
Mr chair so my question is would you be
in favor of an
increase that re would would be after
the tax if there's a tax increase in the
other states and if we at 25 cents
below maybe a dollar or whatever their
increase so if their increas is about a
dollar that's what we're hearing if we
were only increase our 75 cents and did
it after like 30 days after theirs went
into effect do you think that would
negatively impact your
business I think any increase will
against foot traffic coming in to the
stores uh within any
increase it it it just slows traffic so
I think any increase at all will you
know slow down traffic in our stores and
revenue to our stores okay thank
you okay thank you for your testimony
thank
you okay I still have six uh people to
testify um
so if what you're saying is something
that's already been said please uh keep
that to a minimum thank you uh next I
have um Max
Hager good morning folks uh thank you
for having me today my name is Max Hagar
Salem New Hampshire uh I represent root
Vapors we have four direct uh Vapor
related stores uh we do not sell
cigarettes uh we don't sell any other
tobacco products uh one thing I think
that this
uh needs to be clear is that I do not
believe Vapor Products are tobacco
products it's a nicotine product it is
only nicotine that you're ingesting it
is what is addictive uh but it does not
cause any of the concerns of the
American Cancer Society or the American
Health
Association compared to traditional
combustible tobacco so I want to be
clear that I believe that this bill
represents a lump lumping two categories
of one industry the nicotine industry uh
I don't think it's fair to the vapor
industry whatsoever uh we've been fair
with the state throughout all means to
adhere to all regulations that have been
put forth we've work with you to assure
that we comply with taxation
lenser uh everything that should be done
in a normal business you expect that
from a good industry uh we try to
provide that what I would ask from you
now is if you're looking to increase
taxes or Revenue off of these it's an
easy solution there's already means of
collecting this tax I don't believe it's
being done properly I don't believe that
you're getting your full share uh I as a
small business owner see
larger businesses around me getting away
with fraud I am not going to be the one
that throws other industry people under
the bus but let me tell you they're not
paying their taxes simple as that so if
you're looking to increase it you're
just going to increase the black market
you're going to increase the amount of
uh uh Exodus from our sales here in the
state to other states or God forbid
online which you all think is not
existing any longer that is still a
viable option for these consumers uh if
you think that they can only buy this in
the store you're highly mistaken uh I
just want to be clear there is no
increase of an 8 to 65%
on a product that gives people a better
choice to use nicotine a healthier
choice we could do the homework I'll sit
down with anybody okay but this is a
devastating thing to have to happen and
if you want to get people off of tobacco
the first choice is going to an
alternative nicotine product that First
Choice should not be as expensive with
all the uh luggage that traditional
tobacco has carried for all these years
this is a new product it's been out for
about 20 years the cigarettes have been
out for 200 if you guys or if we can't
clearly separate the two when we move
forward with these sort of things then
we really need to expand our knowledge
on what we're dealing with it would be
like saying that uh uh alcohol is the
same as fruit juice okay there's there's
bad things with both okay but one does
harmful harmful things and one does some
not so good things
uh I would like to talk for 10 20
minutes I know you don't have the time
but I would be more than happy to sit
down with anybody to discuss a real
solution going forward for the vapor
industry here in the states to make your
Revenue
better thank you uh I have a question
here
represent yeah thank you for your
testimony I'm curious about your
question your statement about the black
market do you characterize the black
market for Vaping in a percent of the
total Market
the black market had taken off
approximately 2018 2019 when the federal
uh regulations came into effect either
barring small businesses from offering a
product to their consumer or offering
new product to the market after that
date so it created a black market based
upon the accessibility of the need or
the want of the consumer to get this
access and the Federal Regulations Andor
state regulations taking away that
option so it basically was a an
immediate result of a federal regulatory
uh attack on the industry at the time if
they had taken a smaller steps that it's
called the pmta process of getting your
Market to mark your product to Market
properly they screwed it all up simple
as that and they created the Brock
Market follow followup please uh yeah my
question was the extent of the black
market is this like half your business
is Black Market or a small part or a
large part can you comment on
that if if we're talking about how much
loss Revenue you you're losing out on
the table it would be at least 50% at
least 50% I only know 50% of the
industry that's doing it right and
that's because there is no way that they
can do it the right way to be clear 30
cents per milliliter we were this is a
clear this is why tobacco and nicotine
and cigarettes and Vapors 30 cents per
milliliter is one of the only states
that does this it's a very awkward way
of doing it at the time we had less than
one milliliter in a throwaway device
less than 1 milliliter approximately 30
cents per unit we're now talking about
units that have 20 to 25 milliters in
them you're talking a tax of $758 per
unit and guess what this is what we're
talking about the Lost Revenue they're
bringing these small devices in Black
Market to the state selling them without
a tax on it and you're losing out on the
revenue I'm not you can come to any one
of my stores and audit but if you did
that to every convenience store and Head
smoke shop in this city or this state
you would find an abundance of Il legal
product that is not being paid
for yes representative you said Thank
you Mr chairman thank you Max for your
uh testimony is is there a way to S I'm
going to make one suggestion as you walk
from this building over to the
governor's office and and suggest uh to
one of her staffers that this is a
component that her new committee Co
might want to look at uh because
everybody should be paying their fair
share uh is there a way much like a pack
of cigarettes there's a tax stamp on the
bottom is there a way for a consumer to
walk into a into a storefront and ID
whether that tax has been
paid uh currently there is no way for
them to ticket or tab or sticker any
specific product that I'm aware of it is
something that could be done uh I know
that there would be a cost behind you
know tagging every single item that goes
out the door uh but currently no it is
on the onus of the distributor selling
into the state to collect the
tax as simple as
that thank representative ORS so uh
thank you Mr chair and uh thank you for
your testimony so is it just the vaping
products that is the black market
problem is not the cigarette
products I don't want to speak on a
since I do not handle any other uh
industry the tobacco is cigarettes and
vapor and since I don't sell cigarettes
uh I could just say that enough people
still get their cigarettes and as I had
mentioned like online you would might
not think it's available you might not
think that's a thing they still get
their products online but secondary as
to what I see people coming up the same
person that walks into my vapor store
will go to the next uh uh convenience or
gas station or tobacco retailer and buy
their cigarettes while they're here as
well they might have made the change to
Vapor their wife might still be on
cigarettes their parents might still be
on vapor and their kids are on
cigarettes and when I say kids it's a
7-year-old that comes into my store and
purchases this product and then says my
50-year-old son still smokes can you
believe it I got to go over and buy a
cotton but yes we're seeing it but I
can't I can't directly relate to how
much uh loss Revenue in tobacco cigar
sales and in conjunction with uh
representative duet said that's what we
were Hearing in testimony yesterday
about all the products coming into this
country that are not paying the tax
they're being flooded like through China
wherever thank
you okay thank you for your
testimony next I have Kevin dagel
good afternoon Mr chairman members of
the committee uh for the record my name
is Kevin dagel and I am the President of
the New Hampshire Grocers Association uh
for those of you not familiar with our
group we represent both chain and
independent Grocery and convenience
stores here in New Hampshire I'm here
today to state that an increase in the
cigarette tax will cause economic damage
in New Hampshire will not raise tax
revenues for the state and will do
little to reduce smoking New Hampshire
spent years marketing itself as a
consumer friendly lowcost Haven to our
neighboring states and we currently
enjoy an advantage over those States
when it comes to the tax on cigarettes
this Advantage is one of the driving
factors for over 40% of sales being
attributed to crossb sales reducing this
Advantage not only drives cigarette
sales away but also drives the sales of
additional items away it's not uncommon
that when a customer comes to New
Hampshire to purchase cigarettes they
also spend money on other items such is
bear liquor Lottery groceries snacks gas
stops at a local restaurants stops at a
local shop by discouraging the consumer
from coming to New Hampshire you lose
out on those additional sales and the
taxes on those additional items when
surrounding states raise their cigarette
tax we see an increase in sales here in
New Hampshire so it's not unrealistic to
expect the good portion of those sales
to leave when that pricing is no longer
advantageous they will stop coming to
New Hampshire to purchase their cigarett
and this reduction in sales will almost
certainly have a negative impact on your
tobacco tax
revenue and while the intent behind
increasing cigarette taxes may be to
reduce smoking evidence suggests that
the effectiveness of tax increases
diminishes over time many smokers switch
to cheaper unregulated products negating
the health and revenues the revenue
goals of this tax policy in summary for
the reasons provided we cannot support
this bill we encourage the committee to
oppose House Bill 290 and find it
inexpedient to legislate thank you thank
you any
questions yes represent
ol thank you for taking my question I
greatly appreciate it um just a few
moments ago well maybe half an hour ago
uh we heard the uh two uh preeminent uh
societies fighting uh cigarette smoking
say exactly the opposite of what you're
saying uh do you have any um objective
evidence to that uh that there would be
a decrease in sales and anciliary sales
as
well the advantage we have currently I
know the bill sponsor and others after
him spoke about proposed tax increases
in other states we have to go by what
the tax is today yeah proposals Hit or
Miss um by raising our tax right now
we're going to be
78% 78 cents more than main anything
along that border is going to see a
reduction in sales so it reducing that
that cost or increasing that cost is
going to reduce the traffic coming over
the Border somebody coming from
Massachusetts it's a dollar more is it
really advantageous for me to pay 25
bucks more for something where I can
stay close closer to home so I I I
disagree with them I I don't think
you'll see a decrease in sales and an
increase in tax you'll see a decrease in
sales and a decrease in your
Revenue representative SP thank you
thank you Mr chair where did you come up
with the 40% are out of state uh sales
where's that figure coming from y
there's several studies that actually
show it's 40 to
45% your very own Liquor Commission
touts that their sales from cross B
Sales anywhere from 50 to
55% okay followup follow up so we would
if if we raised it a dollar we wouldn't
see all 40% of that loss would
we it it depends upon the person you'd
see a good number of that loss depending
upon which side of the Border you're on
well but it appears that you wouldn't
see a complete if we did lose all 40% of
that there would be about 60 million in
Revenue that we would lose in tax
revenue based on the total revenue from
uh tobacco can't hypothesize as to what
the percentage of that 40% loss would be
I can tell you what the percentage of
those sales are and that's 40% of those
sales are cross B of of T of cigarettes
correct right so if we if we got if we
lost all that that would be about 60
million in tax revenue correct but his
bill would get us 87 million in tax
revenue so if we lost all that cross
border we'd still have more revenue from
the from the bill you'd also lose
additional sales people filling up on
gas stopping in a restaurant fall 40%
there thank
you represent
opal thank you Mr chairman um Mr Delo
the 40% figure you cited that's not just
Maine correct that is that's all cross
crossb sales so that would include
Massachusetts which would still be
significantly higher than um and and my
guess is composes a fairly subst
stantial portion of that
40% and it would include Vermont which
would I think we'd be 30 cents cheaper
if without you be 30 cents cheaper I
think it's I think it's 30 cents cheaper
just on a pack of cigarettes and and I
and I assume as somebody else has
pointed out ront also has a sales tax
correct so that the the actual cost to
the consumer would be more than that 30
cents if they were buying it in Vermont
versus buying it in the Hampshire you
get to a Tipping Point of what justifies
me jumping in my car and making that
that drive to to the other state thank
you and that's different for
everyone repres to said Thank you Mr
chairman and I'm going to offer this
question and maybe I should have asked
it earlier to anybody that may be coming
up to speak and maybe to some of the
previous speakers we're talking a lot
about the cross border Revenue
opportunities does anybody know how many
adult taxpaying gred Staters smoke or
vape because we're talking about taxing
our own citizens at a higher rate right
now too so I'd like to know if maybe
your organization has that number or
some somebody in the room may or may not
have that number I don't have that
number at the ready something we could
look at possibly get to you thank you
representative
Aly thank you on in the past our
committee has been told quite a lot
about the um efforts that we are
required to take to stop the black
market in
tobacco uh has nothing to do with
vaping uh and in order to be able to
still get the 40 million plus dollars
that comes from the tobacco
settlement uh that money seems a little
bit smaller every year but but on do you
have any evidence that there is
significant on
illegal sales of tobacco in this
state despite the the currently we're
not aware of any are taken every
industry has it's bad actors I mean from
time to time they do pop up um thank I I
believe y
you okay thank you for your
testimony Dr Deborah
Warner oh the next bill okay good that's
one less we have to do right
now thank you uh Tom Bry
Mr chairman committee members thank you
for your time this morning uh my name is
Tom fry I'm a resident of lime New
Hampshire I'm president of summit
Distributing uh we're a New Hampshire
based company that is a convenience
store operator and petroleum distributor
that has locations in New Hampshire
Vermont and Massachusetts that we
operate and I Supply over 90 independent
customers throughout New England uh with
petroleum products happen to be a
volunteer EMT and an officer of the
Upper Valley Wilderness response team
that supports fishing game so if anybody
getss lost we're here to help uh I'm
currently chairman of the oil fund
dispersement board in New Hampshire I'm
speaking today in opposition of HB 290
because I operate New Hampshire stores
and in neighboring states I'm able to
speak pretty knowledgy about how to
state tobacco policy can quickly impact
where customers choose to buy their
products and other sales as was
previously mentioned for example when
Massachusetts raised its tobacco tax to
350 1 our Massachusetts St store saw a
sharp decrease 15 to 18% in tobacco
sales and as I mentioned every customer
that comes into one of our retail
convenience stores buys approximately 11
to $14 of additional goods and services
not um excluding gasoline so that went
away okay so that's a revenue loss to us
New Hampshire was the benefit my New
Hampshire stores reap the benefit of
that I should note when Massachusetts
band flavored tobacco in 2020 our stores
in Vermont New Hampshire saw a dramatic
increase in sales while Massachusetts
suffered the consequences and now are
dealing with a as has been previously
mentioned a pretty significant Black
Market problem because they eliminated
Menthol which contributes to 20 to 25%
of our cigarette
Sales New Hampshire more than any other
state New England has gotten tobacco tax
policy right by maintaining a relatively
low excise tax we've been able to
capitalize on our autate visitors by
maintaining a relatively
low to take make their purchases in
doing so we've pulled in outof state tax
dollars uh without burdening our instate
residents in fact the recent tax
Foundation study published back in
December of 24 states that New Hampshire
has been the recipient of $950 million
of out ofate tax
dollars so the same thoughtful policy is
demonstrated in the way we currently tax
Vape products uh a bifurcated tax of 30
cents per milliliter for closed and 8%
for open is the fairest way to tax these
products moving to a 65% tax wholesale
price only gives our regional tax
advantage away uh B by my math it makes
us uncompetitive with Maine and also
Vermont based on that new tax rate my
advice don't change a thing as our newly
elected governor aot said don't m things
up I urge you to move forward with this
bill and consider the negative
consequences of proposed tax increases
on tobacco products uh thank you very
much I'd be glad to answer any
questions
questions seeing none thank you very
much thank you very
much um I may not be saying this right
right but the last one I hear
is oh
Bri SC Brett Scot Brett Scott
okay
Scot y my name is Brett Scott and the
president of New Hampshire Vapor
Association and also the owner president
of Smoker's Haven I own 19 retail stores
and employ 100 70 people uh throughout
my
businesses I just want to touch
primarily on The Vape piece that there
was a Senate Bill 433 which formed a
committee to study the tax collection uh
for Vape
products and they themselves all voted
in favor of you know having this
committee and we are expecting a Senate
bill to uh change the way that the tax
is collected and who enforces it this is
a major issue in the state right now
cigarettes have attack stamp there is
tight control of of making sure that
those products have been taxed when
they're in the retail stores these Vape
products that is not the case there is
no trackability the current audit
process is a joke that we have in the
state there are millions of dollars
being left on the table I heard someone
ask what the amount is now obviously
that's difficult to say but I wanted to
get some information so a while ago I
started pushing on this issue I
requested information of what the state
had actually collected in Vape tax and I
found that my 11 stores that I have in
New Hampshire because I have stores in
Maine and New Hampshire my 11 stores in
New Hampshire we're paying
26% of the tax that's being collected
for Vape here in the state of New
Hampshire now my ego would love to think
that we have 26% market share in the
state that is not the case it is not
realistic there are hundreds of licensed
tobacco retailers these Vape taxes are
being paid by you know convenience
stores smoke shops all that many of you
probably wonder how are there so many
smoke shops when you drive down certain
strips that is primarily because these
guys are evading the taxes and is
extremely lucrative because they are
keeping not only their cut but your cut
this is a major problem now you would
think when you look at this 8% cuz I
hear that getting pushed around a lot
that well that's not a significant
number 30 cents a milliliter is where
the real tax money is that's a lot more
than 8% sure 8% might have been a
smaller amount to start this and 30
cents a milliliter was you know seen as
that too as the market changed that 30
cents per milliliter became a
significant amount of tax and often is
resulting an extremely high tax on these
products and again making it very
lucrative for those that aren't paying
the tax
so first I would ask that I'm hopeful
that the Senate bill will come through
and changing how it's collected enforce
it and I would love to be a part of that
because this is a major problem in the
state before we raise the tax I would
love for us to have a process that truly
audits these people I would ask if you
came into this room today and if the
heat wasn't working if you would turn it
on or turn around and try to get an
entirely new HVAC system turned on uh
installed because it's the same type of
thing we need to fix what we already
have before we go and increase it and
put us that are actually following the
rules you know at a huge disadvantage
and jeopardize our businesses to these
people that aren't doing it right so I'd
be happy to answer any
questions represent El thank you very
much for taking uh my question uh we've
heard a little bit today about uh the
issue of tax evasion and and fraud
against the state um
and I believe that that may exist and
the reporting by the various uh bodies
has been
sincere however do you have any um
anything other than anecdotal
information that we could use yeah I
mean I think the greatest example I say
is the fact of I I pulled this
information from Dr of how much are they
collecting per month and I know how much
I'm paying in tax and when I did those
numbers I'm paying 26% of what the state
is collecting of Vape tax and I'm
selling that out of 11 stores here in
the
state there's hundreds of license
tobacco
retailers okay thank you very much for
where you got your data I appreciate
that that thank you gives us a place to
start thank
you any other questions what percent of
the market do you think you
are I my last understanding was there
was around 900 licensed tobacco
retailers in this state so I would think
that I
well below 5% um I think even that would
be
exaggerating so okay all right thank you
thank you very much okay oh we I'm sorry
we have one more question represent yes
thank you do you remember the number of
the bill and this was this year's bill
or last year's Bill last year it was
Senate Bill 433 is what tasked them to
have the committee to study this oh oh
yeah okay I think that's the way that uh
Senator Lang is pushing something out
from N I agree with that which I'm
signed on to okay thank you great thank
you okay last but not least I have
Loreno Sullivan
Dr you know what
thank you welcome thank you Mr chairman
members of the committee I'm Jennifer
Ramsey I'm tax policy counsil with the
Department of Revenue new Administration
and this is Lauren O Sullivan she's our
senior financial analyst um we're just
handing out to you a quick guide we
contributed to the fiscal note for this
bill um and that provides you with just
a little bit more information about how
we arrived at our
calculations um you may recall that the
commissioner told you yesterday that the
tobacco tax is really three taxes
there's the tobacco stamp sales there's
other tobacco products and then there
are ecigarettes um this bill only
touches the tobacco stamps sales and the
ecigarettes and would raise the rates
for for both of those products um we
analyzed the fiscal impact of the
proposed legislation by looking at
simply fiscal year 24 sales data um we
did not make any adjustments for the
possible impact um of increased or
decreased sales that changing the rate
of tax might uh provide so looking
strictly at fiscal year 24 data we
calculated that um a change in the
tobacco stamp rate of a dollar um would
result in approximately 87.5 million of
additional revenue for New Hampshire uh
assuming sales stayed steady and we
calculated that with respect to um The
increased rate for wholesale ecigarette
products um there would be an increase
in approximately $3 million per um year
in sales we were not able to calculate
uh an increase for the
um open systems yes for sorry for the
closed systems because those are taxed
on a per millimeter basis and this
legislation would change those to a
wholesale price our tax system does not
capture the wholesale price of those
products it only captures the per
millimeter price so there would probably
be an additional impact that we're not
able to calculate with the data that we
have um and if there are questions I'm
happy to take those yes
represent um yeah a couple in different
topics uh the first topic is since it's
fresh in my mind and may disappear in a
couple of seconds uh the gentleman that
was just up here uh spoke about uh
comparative data uh that he obtained is
it possible that Dr could provide us
with that uh analysis as to how how many
smoke shops exist that sell vaping
products
that pardon legal Le well that was the
next line you understand where I'm going
with with that particular line of
questioning and I think both sides uh
would uh appreciate uh receiving that uh
data from uh directly from Dr as to the
shops that sell it and the shops that
pay the taxes on it right so um yes we
can provide you with that information
the retailers are currently licensed by
the um Liquor Commission and we license
the
wholesalers um so that I believe that
retail data is also available uh we'll
have to get that from The Liquor
Commission but they can provide that
information for you I would yes I would
appreciate coordinating with the other
agencies the necessary to provide that
information um and the other question I
have if I might follow up follow up uh
do you have any data based on uh sales
or tax stamp sales uh regarding an
increase in price Visa the increase in
sales so if we increase the sales tax is
there an increase decrease in sales
compared to revenues um so with the
analysis we did we did not look at what
the effect on the volume of sales would
be based on a price increase um and I've
heard a lot of testimony from people
here today I don't disagree that there
would be some impact
we don't have the ability within what
what we know uh to be able to calculate
that number I think the commissioner
told you yesterday that we we are um
45th in of the 50 states in terms of um
being a uh a state where people from out
of state come here to purchase
cigarettes and you've heard a lot of
testimony about the price differences
between um the tax here versus around in
our surrounding states I think it's fair
to assume that there would be some um
reduction in sales but maybe not um as
much as you would see if you started to
raise our tax rates to closer to our
neighboring
states okay thank you representative
duet thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question shame on me I've read
the reports before but it just notice
that the the revenue line for the it's
for open systems is there a way to get a
static analysis on closed systems any
way to see what that actual revenue is
because we're hearing testimony that at
some level there's uh evasion and tax
being paid so so with respect to the um
the closed systems that are priced on a
per milliliter basis um we were asked to
look at that uh during the study
committee this summer as well um that
was created under SP 433 um we don't
have the information that we need to do
that we would need to have wholesale
pricing data from resellers we have
volumes within our system but we don't
have the price the wholesale price of
those products so we would need to reach
out to wholesalers to get that price
information follow up follow up does
that make sense to you in any way shap
or form to to do it that way or would
would you have a suggestion as to how we
could track this more appropriately Dr
can come to us with a with a number and
say this is what the revenue is are you
looking for a fiscal impact for the the
uh closed systems that are sold on a per
Mill M millimeter basis yes what what
what the actual tax revenue for 24 was
you know bottom bottom line number sorry
we do have the data for the revenue for
24 I'm sorry I thought you were talking
about the the impact of this legislation
but you can separate the open and closed
systems okay I'm wondering why it's not
here do you do have that with
us split between the so the the reason
that's not on the reason it's not on the
fiscal note or the quick guide is
because we couldn't calculate the tax
impact but um I know we do provide
monthly the breakout between um between
the open and
actually we we could um I I can email
the committee the breakout between the
open and close I know that was requested
yesterday during the presentation that
has been prepared okay thank you sorry
it wasn't yesterday today thank you Mr
chairman representative
opal thank you Mr chairman um and and
thank you for this I'm
assuming um and and maybe I shouldn't do
that maybe I should simply ask you um uh
to I'm assuming you could prepare a
history of the tobacco tax I'm assuming
it hasn't been at its current level in
perpetuity um and that we've raised it
before the state has raised it before
and I'm
assuming again that having that history
that we could take a look back at
whenever we last raised the sales the
the the tax on Tobacco that we could
also look at sales prior to that tax
increase and after that would give us at
least some ability to understand what
might happen not that not that history
is always as what what are
the investment guides say you know
history is no guarantee of future
results but um but certainly you know it
might give us a guide is that possible
sure so I believe the uh tobacco stamp
tax has been at the same rate since
2008 um and so we would have been on a
different Revenue system you heard
yesterday about our Revenue information
system that would have been the old
Tim's system I'm not sure how much
detail data we can get but certainly on
an aggregate basis we could look at data
from those years um and and provide you
with some sense of how the revenue
changed when that rate changed um the
ecigarette product rates have just been
in effect since 2020 and that data that
we have is it hasn't changed so
yeah well obviously it may be imperfect
it may be imperfect but I think it would
be helpful um along with the request
from representative
okay thank you for your testimony thank
you well oh I'm sorry Scott represent
Brier uh thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question uh I had a
quick question about regarding the te
potential tax evasion on the U
ecigarettes um are you familiar with um
the tobacco uniformity project being
done by the Federation of tax
administrators yes um
followup uh my question is um do you
have any data in there that talks about
the best way to reduce tax evasion on
the ecigarettes um through Federation of
tax administrators as like a best
practices guide would you be able to
provide any of that information to this
committee you remember that right right
yeah um we can we can look and see what
we have and provide you what we can find
yeah thank
you now I think we are all said Thank
you thank
you okay that concludes uh today's
testimony is there anyone else that
didn't fill out a pin card who would
like to say
something okay with that I will close
the public
hearing
on HB 290
right so we have a little flexibility
yeah
e
e e
okay the time being
11:50 we will uh I'll open the public
hearing on HB 328 and recognize
representative Ames
so good
morning and um I see many many familiar
faces um friends on both sides of the
aisle and it's uh so I'm glad to glad to
be here welcome um it's
uh I think appropriate and a very
good a way to come back to this hearing
room with a bill that is a good bill and
it's a very bipartisan bill um with a
number
of you up there
um uh part of the process that led to
this bill and some of you on on the bill
itself um so
uh it's House Bill 328 I'm introducing
that uh I'm the prime sponsor there are
a whole bunch of uh
co-sponsors uh senators and state reps
um and
uh the uh the ease with which I had uh
in gathering support for this bill meant
that I didn't have to do anything uh it
was great uh and representative om by
the way uh welcome back uh it's good to
see you um so this uh
reflects change in the gaming systems
the gaming
industry gaming practices here in New
Hampshire that um has uh transformed the
industry I believe just in the past few
years um and I think it dates to the
time when uh it became possible for
gaming operat ERS to um
open their Halls that they had or the
open new halls um and put in place the
historic horse racing
machines that uh enabled a new way of
doing business um and uh I imagine that
in your Revenue uh work that you're
seeing more Revenue coming in um uh via
the his course racing um uh activity uh
than you might have expected um so um
that's that's the
background uh last year uh it's really
last uh session two-year
session
um a commission that's the predecessor
the to the commission that's proposed in
this bill um was set up and uh members
of that worked hard representative
janigian was on that representative
duet
um I think that
was it and if it wasn't speak up um and
it was chaired by Patrick abrami and
another um former member of this
committee uh he did an excellent job and
um and worked very hard as did uh the
rest of us and uh another uh person who
was on the that commission who's who's
uh uh Gone on uh to to uh more relaxed
life I hope is Senator
dallesandro um so we had quite a quite a
group and uh we had some money and with
that money um the uh Spectrum
um I don't know what the full title
of the uh Spectrum gaming group uh was
hired and uh did a lot of good work for
us so as background I want to say that
you have I think it's been passed around
a copy of the report of
the gaming
commission what you don't have but I
understand I understand that you can get
it are are the two reports that came out
of the work of this gaming commission
the two reports from the spectrum that
came out of the work of this uh
commission one is a a gaming market
analysis and Regulatory assessment
that's my copy there and U the other is
a social impact study overview of
responsible gaming and problem gambling
best practices in the United
States lots lots of interesting
important information in both of these
reports um and I encourage you to read
them I they are available online and I I
think Jen has uh uh giv you information
on how to get at them um but I'll leave
that between you and Jen to figure that
one out um so lots of information and
lots of incomplete work that couldn't be
done last year and that's why this bill
is before you um it's uh House Bill 328
establishing a charitable gaming
oversight
commission um it
um it would set up this commission for a
10-year period of
time uh so it's a a long it was it's
truly a standing oversight commission
with uh a series of duties obligations
expectations basic basically a charge to
the commission that's in the uh
legislation and um with a membership
that's that uh has nine voting members
and another six non- voting members the
voting members are all from the
legislature I believe and um and the
other six are from
outside uh and is designed to ensure
input not just from those who benefit
from or participate in uh chable gaming
right now but uh to the broader public
uh so that uh uh truly all perspectives
can be heard and and uh be present in
the uh thinking and activities of the
commission
um and I think what I'll do because I
know there are a few other people who uh
may want to talk and uh and that uh the
lunch hour is just about upon us um is
just to go through the charge to this
commission and um urge you to uh
to uh vote favorably for the bill um
with whatever small changes you may wish
to make I do while I think of it I want
to point out there is one mistake just a
drafting error I think um on page two
line
19 of the bill um it should be part two
article 83 not part
one sure you got that um so uh the
charges uh uh in the overall char charge
is to oversee the implementation of char
gaming laws including historical horse
race gaming consider the issues
identified in the nove November 1 2024
final report of the commission that's
the report that you
have um including the newly authorized
horse historical horse
races and um and shall make from time to
time time such recommendations for
administrative and legislative changes
to charal gaming law and rules rules as
it deems necessary and
appropriate uh down below uh at line
25 uh the commission is uh directed to
submit a report that would uh uh fulfill
that uh obligation that I just read um
annually in uh I believe it's
uh um November in
November and uh um the particular issues
that the commission is charged to look
at and make recommendations uh regarding
our changes needed to address problem
gambling um definitely needs to be
addressed I urge you to look at this
social impact study and think about it
um changes that may be needed to
restructure or modify systems for
allocating and overseeing the use of
funds granted to the state and to
Charities and gaming operations ERS
participating in um this this gambling
activity um and then uh a third one
that's very important I think I think
this is going to require thought and I
uh that'll be interested to follow the
uh changes needed to prevent undue
concentration or prolifer or
proliferation of gaming locations
facilities and ownership including a
municipal option oped into or out of
components of charal gaming
um I think you must know that uh that
the casinos that have been developed in
this um state in the last two or three
or four years just very quickly um are
largely owned by outside uh of the of
State owners and um have Consolidated
down to just a few
um that's worth taking a look at what
are the implications of that what can we
do about
it
um and uh there is this possibility the
uh gaming uh report from Spectrum this
large report suggests that there's no
real reason not to
call um historic horse racing what it
really is which is um gambling by slot
machine
and
um and move over to um
enable allow slot machines in New
Hampshire and thereby avoid the software
fees and other fees that are associated
right now with running historic horse
racing machines and then capture that
money that's quite a lot of money so
think about that uh slot machines uh in
the minds of of uh a large number of
people in New Hampshire do not have uh
do not sound good as you see it doesn't
it's not a good sound um but maybe uh we
need to get over that since it's
basically the same of what as what it's
been authorized a little faster but
otherwise the
same um so that's worth thinking about
and
um I think this commission is is needed
one other aspect of the the problem is
uh charal gaming all of a sudden we're
getting a lot more money flowing into uh
the the uh slot that's for charitable
Charities for Charities to be allocated
to Charities it's a lot of money and
who's that money going to is going to
the Charities that have managed to get
on to the list at uh these casinos how
do they get onto that casin that list
what are the standards uh who picks them
um who gets the best days who gets the
worst days and so forth and so on it's a
lot of money there that is uh right now
flowing um pursuant to choices that are
made by the gaming operators because
they're the ones that are making the
choices there's really no no standard in
place in the law uh that governs those
uh questions that I just raised so um
that's another aspect of the need for
this commission it's really a very
important issue so that's the way I'll
leave it uh I hope that you'll support
this bill and uh send it forward and if
there's any fixes that are need needed I
I uh I welcome
them thank
you representative
ery thank you representative Ames and
thank you again for another uh well put
together Bill uh just to syis real
quickly this bill is uh put together to
indicate that um from a study committee
the study committee unanimously uh
author or study commission authorized
and suggested to the legislature that
the commission be reauthorized
reinstituted for a 10-year period to
discuss the Myriad issues that you had
uh that you raised in here as a cause
for the committee not to be addressed by
this
uh directly but for the commission to
address is that correct that is correct
and the second question I have
followup would be uh do you find that
the uh the error on line 19 page two was
clerical in nature therefore a
scribner's error therefore could be
corrected at any time without Amendment
yeah thank
you representative duet thank you Mr
chairman and I thank my friend and
colleague from Jeffrey I I know and the
work this committee has done over the
last bunch of years the scope and scale
of charitable
gaming needs this okay needs this and it
it would take a ream of paper this thick
if we were go to go through issue by
issue as to what is fair and Equitable
and charitable gaming in relation to the
charities quickly reading over this and
I've co-sponsored this with you and
you're well aware we're we're going to
see as a committee a lot of gaming bills
uh I've authed a couple but but my issue
here specifically and shame on me for
not touching Bas with you earlier is the
voting members you have two members of
the Senate five members of the house but
you also have the executive director of
Lottery and the AG voting and I know
that in our commission over the summer
they abstained from that and and that
would be a change that I would want to
make in this in that they they probably
shouldn't be voting members of this
commission um just throwing it out there
yeah
I um well thank you for uh pointing out
that issue um I think that uh I'm fine
either way I think they're invaluable
members of the commission um my
experience going back many years to the
time when I chaired um the big
Commission on uh casino gambling back in
2013 something like that
um with a commission that included the
attorney general who was obligated by
the bill that it passed uh to be
present personally present at all the uh
Casino meetings and uh and the lottery
director was also a member was said
again that they they were both
invaluable to the work of the uh
commission and it's okay with me if
there's a design possibility but uh it
can go either way I I'm sure they'll
contribute either way and as you pointed
out uh the um on most issues they would
abstain they would not vote because of
uh that tradition thank you just to
follow up yeah I don't want to paint
them into a corner or give them any
exposure and I think it's the duty of
the legisl legislature to make what
decisions need to be made in this
commission that's yeah I'm fine with
that so I totally agree the value is is
beyond you know but they need to be
involved so that that's my only concern
okay thank
you represent
elme thank you uh
there we have at present no guard
rails on these machines for people that
are uh addicted and playing addicted and
cannot get off of it and there are other
things that I'm sure in this report that
are things that that many people would
probably like
see uh
that that the companies that the three
companies that are now in charge of all
of these machines um would not like to
see and I am wondering if since they
are almost completely slot machines uh
if we were to
hold that gift to them Hostage to
negotiate guard rails and the other
items that the commission thought were
important to
impose um any
uh you know there are many ways to go
forward and uh um there doesn't have to
be um this is going to be a process
number one it's complicated uh problem
gambling is complicated and it's uh diff
difficult difficult to get at I think uh
the truth is that many of the gaming
operators would like to
um uh will'll be on the side of Reform
and uh introduction into the system of a
number of interventions that our
neighboring state in Massachusetts uh
utilizes uh for example and uh they've
got big time gaming operators so I think
I think that the resistance will not be
what you um suggested there um maybe at
the margins it will be but uh and maybe
the margins are most important I don't
know um but uh I I'd say go ahead and
try to develop the best possible uh um
program for um helping those who have
the addiction that you mentioned uh and
those who engage otherwise in at a
problematic level in uh gambling and um
develop the interventions that make
sense and uh I don't know about holding
hostage that's sort of a different kind
of
strategy representative Malloy thank you
Mr chair thank you for taking my
question representative Ames it is nice
to see you there thank you for the work
uh I serve on two nonprofit boards that
have benefited from the uh charitable
gaming
Arrangement uh and they've in my the
questions I get about this is the how
how Charities are chosen to uh receive
the the
benefit should this H commission be
established and that question get
addressed
uh how long a period of time are we
looking looking at before we could see
something down on paper if at all about
what those rules and regulations could
be and and how and I realize that's a
question that's probably maybe
impossible to answer but if you could
take a stab at it I appreciate well I uh
I
share what I guess is your view and I
know representative Aly suggested this
too in her
question uh the the feeling that
um that we're already late in
addressing um many many issues in this
uh um sort of astonishing rise of uh of
uh machine gambling in in New Hampshire
and um and so the sooner the better but
how you get there I'm not sure um and I
don't know whether there's a particular
bill that would allow one part or
another of this uh to be addressed
separately uh I'd like to see the whole
thing addressed particularly chart CH
responsible gambling or or problem
gambling however you want to phrase it
um the sooner the better on that but
it's got to be done
right yes represent
elberger thank you Mr chair and it's
pleasure to have you back uh just to
follow up on that I I believe we've
talked about this this in the last term
but when we're when this commission
would be looking at selection of
Charities would there be
criteria for
example one of the groups that I know
because they told me benefits from
charitable gaming is the New Hampshire
State Police bagpipe band now I I think
they do I enjoy bagpipe music as opposed
to many who don't but it seems to me odd
that basically the state is giving them
money to play the bag pipes at events as
opposed to that money going to things
like uh organizations that provide
health care or shelter or educational
opportunities so I'm wondering if part
of what you would be looking at would be
why would we choose this kind of Charity
as opposed to
another well well that's that's the
problem there is no standard right now
it's going to be difficult to establish
standards because some people will say
we should always should be prioritizing
uh bag pipes you know or something
comparable who's going to pick and
choose can you set up a system that will
do the picking and choosing that's
generally thought to be a fair system um
um I don't know these these are
questions that didn't need to be asked
before when the level of charal gaming
was small now they really need to be
answered because there a lot of money
flowing to this that or the other
charity just because they happen to be
in the door the first before some other
people or some other organization and uh
um I think it's going to be tough making
those choices um I don't know yeah thank
you yes um represent and Then followed
by thank you Mr chair and just in the
interest of time we we could talk for
hours about that that's part of the
purpose and correct me if I'm if I'm
wrong representative but that's part of
the purpose who's going to pick winners
and losers we can't pick winners or
losers a charity is a charity whether
it's bag pipes stove pipes it's it's a
charity and that's that's my
understanding or at least the position
I'm coming from that needs to be a fair
and Equitable way to distribute the
funds also keeping in mind and we've
spoken about it in this committee
Charities that have been on board since
2006 I think it was or 2008 the
so-called Legacy Charities that have
built out Service
delivery from from charitable gaming and
provide a service to residents of our
communities built on revenue for this so
so it's going to be a balancing act
correct me if I'm I'm wrong but it's
going to be a balancing act and it's
going to be labor intensive uh
bipartisan and everybody has to have
buying in this and and make sure it's
fair and Equitable because of the the
scope of gaming at this point every
charity in the state wants to get
involved and rightfully so let let's see
how we can best deliver those dollars
dolls that this commission should do
that if there was a question to me I I
agree would you I kept asking if if I'm
incorrect that was a would you
believe um yes I mean I was I was on
this commission as well and through the
commission we found there were more and
more questions coming up and and that's
one of the reasons that this bill is
here because we want to start answering
these questions um I'd like to think
representative Ames has the answers to
all these things but uh we will uh
that's hopefully what the what the
ongoing commission will will accomplish
so
yes
representative um to add to The
Balancing Act I would think too there
should be um oh good to see you thank
you for taking my question comment um do
you think the list should also include
um some kind of protocol for when one of
these sites closes or when another one
opens you mean a g a gambling site yeah
eventually yeah
yes well yes I think uh um that gets to
how
many there should be and
um the degree to which there's
regulation and placement
and size I mean there there are lots of
questions that are out there and uh
right now we've sort of got we've sort
of got a moratorium on the
number um that's supposed to go away
then what and there's uh another issue
that's in in this bill about uh opt in
or opt out for municipalities and uh so
lot and what about municipalities
they're already there and then uh then a
town opts out you know
what what about that situation
representative home knows that issue
well these are these are a lot of uh
good and important questions and I would
encourage uh once this commission does
get uh restarted that people pay
attention to it and you know be involved
maybe make suggestions um one more
question that I want to move on thank
you Mr chairman I I just have one one
quick question I'm I'm just curious
I the thinking whether it was a a
decision or there is some law regarding
uh making the four citizens with no
financial interest non- voting members
as opposed to having some citizen voting
input I'm just curious what the thinking
was yeah a fair question I uh
um just was trying to make it un uh
wieldy rather than
unwieldy I think that's probably where
that comes from as I thought it through
I thought uh we surely needed to have uh
the representatives and Senators um and
that they I thought they should take the
lead but they should but the citizen
citizen involvement should be set up in
a way that the citizens would always be
there as part of the discussion on the
only place where they drop out is in
voting it's my thought
my okay thank you representative mes
uh next I have Alicia
Preston thank you Mr chairman members of
the committee my name is Alicia Preston
and I'm here representing the New
Hampshire charitable gaming operators
Association and we'll be very brief we
are here in support of this legislation
for many years we have worked with
various committees and commissions um
hopefully being a good resource And
discussing the evolving industry and we
would really appreciate the opportunity
to continue doing that with you as we
move
ahead thank you very much
questions seeing none thank you very
much uh next Dr Deborah
Warner and I'll say welcome to the
committee because I know you were an
attendee at virtually every Commission
meeting true I was there um what a
privilege it is to be here to talk to
this fine committee thank you Mr
chairman and members of the committee of
ways and means I'm Dr Deborah Warner I'm
from
Littleton and um I'm an interested
citizen I did attend all of the meetings
in 20124 of the previous commission it
was incredibly interesting and I I was
able to get the car started this morning
at 21 Below and I know representative
Tierney probably had it even
colder oh well it must have been quite a
breeze off of our the river then um
thank you so much for listening to me I
did pass out a um a testimony and it's
written and I have some
notes and I will take off my glasses to
see the notes so um I think that this is
a very very good idea to reiterate the
commission that's already been in place
and also to give it a life of 10 years
it might need longer but you will decide
that in 10 years I think I think it's
like um parent teacher conference in the
developing uh industry here this
industry is Young it is in its formative
years there are uh more local players
now and investors
are scoping us out and there will be
more oh dear something's coming in on my
phone and getting in my hearing I'm
sorry um and so there are going to be
some larger more experienced players
coming into New Hampshire and they will
have an influence as well and I think it
will be very important that the state
keep an eye on how things are developing
and there were just so many things that
the commission did in the report you saw
it it's like 24 26 items that are are
part of the reporting that came out um
as a just a citizen who attended I had
the privilege of being able to speak to
the commission several times I spoke
about local option I also spoke about
I'm a psychologist by the way and I um
have a history in for 15 years heading a
nonprofit counseling center I was able
to speak about the community standards
the industry standards for granting
Charities and um
how things are how they are selected for
Grants the accountability the reporting
out the type of submission and the
criteria that would be involved and I
was very glad that that became a point
to consider in the the next um in the
report and in this bill uh one of the
things that will be studied and um
reported out on the uh charitable
selection process I it's clearly
important to all of us that the money
that's channeled through the state is
going for good purposes that serve the
communities and the best interests of
the most people and and the dire needs
as well
um I would like to make a suggestion I
think you can see it in my notes that I
would like that the public members um
that they be voting members I think that
it helps the voice and the input and the
output of the commission have a very
good depth and breadth of quality
and uh I would very much appreciate that
being considered I would be very welcome
to talk about those things another thing
that I spoke about was um problem
gambling that is an issue you know these
these um casinos that have the ones with
machines make about $20 million or more
multiples of that in a year and the
amount of money allocated for problem
gambling program is in the neighborhood
of
$150,000 and we it was pointed out we
need to have measures of how many
problem gamblers are there and what
happens and how they affect the
community and and what kinds of programs
are good for them uh there's sort of a
hotline that's available and that people
who say they need help they could
perhaps be referred I did stand up at
the New Hampshire Psychological
Association meeting and said how many
people here treat problem gambling and
no one raised their hand among
psychologists I didn't go to the other
professions but um we need to make sure
that the Cadre of your mental health
professionals are also trained and ready
to receive uh the work that needs to be
done so um there we
are I'm good any
questions no seeing thank you very much
thank you so
much okay and last but not least uh we
have New Hampshire lottery here director
McIntyre
and if I can read this right kolie
arago good afternoon Mr chairman uh
Charlie marar live director I know it's
late so I'll be fast um
kulia Royo Chief compliance officer at
the lottery um so the words at design
exist in the bill and you're looking at
the design because I've done seven of
these and i' have no problem um not
obviously be involved but I'm kidding
but most importantly I would ask if you
want to have this commission that you
fund it as well I don't know there's any
funding mechanism currently there and
you're going to need you're gon to have
expenses so I would imagine you'd want
to fund at some level that's decision up
to you that's all I that's all I okay
answer any questions on child gambling
right now I know it's late so I just
want to make sure that I know it's not
this committee regarding funding but
certainly it's important that you be
funded the the last bill Crea the last
Commission Now that you mentioned that
did have funding in it it did yes it had
um I believe it was $150,000 annually
and
non-aps you think and it was expense of
the lottery we we we paid the bill and
it was the bill obviously contains
administratively tied to us uh so our
our CFO and his Department paid the
bills but I just want to make sure that
if you pass the commission okay so this
bill this Bill yes doesn't mention that
um okay well it's a good point yeah uh
represent
elme how much of that money was spent on
Spectrum which seems to be extremely
industry yeah the vast majority of it
was spent on Spectrum their report and
then the report regarding problem gaming
that came was mostly generated by the
mass councel one problem
gam other
questions seeing none thank you very
much thank
you okay is there anyone else who would
like to testify
on HP
328 seeing none I'll close the public
hearing on HB
328 okay now uh
as you noticed by looking at the
schedule our next public hearing is at
1:00 leaving us about half an hour
however the good news is uh that will
should go fairly quickly because it's
been withdrawn by the sponsor but since
it's the clerk been communicating with
the clerk since it's been noticed um I
still have to open the public hearing
and see if anyone's here to testify but
I will be telling anyone who's here to
testify that it's being withdrawn and we
won't be considering it so I'm imagining
that's going to go fast so while it's
scheduled for 1:00 I would say Let's
uh let's be back
by 115 sharp so that we can I don't want
to just in case it takes a little bit
longer I don't want to be cutting into
the next one so so uh we'll come back
from lunch at 1:5 then we have two bills
that I have
have yeah we'll keep you on
track we'll do our best
I'm
e
e e
or 99 they came up with like 800 and
something million
do
e
e e
they've got
property and with equipment ins manufa
okay um the time being um what time is
it 1 oh we're missing one of the
clocks time being
1:26 we'll get
started um before so you probably all
have in your email not that you've seen
it yet but next week's schedule for
Monday the 27th and Tuesday the
28th um after the agency hearings on
Monday the 28th which I expect to end
about 3 o'clock um we're going to exec
three bills which I don't think are is
going to take a ton of time uh 328 which
is the one we just heard public hearing
on to um address the uh Commission on
charitable
gaming uh once
63 which
is
um was 163 house housekeeping dedicated
funds Susan Aly will bring a Amendment
for that uh and then 83 was the raising
the minimum age from 18 to 21 so I want
to ex try to exec those three bills when
we're done with the um the agency
presentations and I think that's going
to be at about three I don't think it's
going to take too much longer than about
half half an hour 45 minutes to do those
three so those will be coming out in an
additional uh email from
Karen
okay yes business question so because of
the timing those will be on the calendar
for next week they will be exact oh yeah
yeah good yeah they'll be on
yep on Monday meeting on Monday yeah on
and Tuesday yes not Monday or Tuesday
what's that I wasn't clear where the the
exec is going to be on Monday or on
Tuesday yeah the exec so Monday we're
doing agency presentations starting at
10 o'clock and I I expect them to end at
about 3: and then we'll exec the three
bills that I just mentioned 328 163 and
83 then on Tuesday we have public
hearings on uh I believe it was six
bills but you'll have it all in your
email so you can see what those are so
Monday and Tuesday we're meeting next
week okay
now um
is there is there anyone here to testify
on HB
234 okay so then let me just announce
that I will be opening the public
hearing on it but that uh the bill has
been
withdrawn so you don't yeah so
um let me just look at my email from the
clerk I think I had open the public
hearing only
if um somebody was here that wanted to
testify
that of course that email is already
buried
now what the
heck why am I not seeing it okay there
it
is
okay okay the clerk said if people show
up to testify on uh that bill HB 234
then we need to hear from them but
they're
being okay we'll let you uh how many do
we just have the one for 234 okay we'll
just cross this
out okay so um then we will not do
anything on 234 it's been withdrawn and
uh where there's no one to testify on it
um there'll be no public hearing
okay great so now we're back on
schedule what did I do with my
pen your
no okay
and uh I should also mention it was the
sponsors that that withdrew the
bill well okay so uh the time being
1:31 I'll open the public hearing on HB
it looks like we're going to hear from
representative
shamberg thank you Mr chairman and
members of the House Ways and Means
Committee I am uh New Hampshire State
Rep Tom shamberg representing marac 6
the towns of Wilman and
Sutton for the last six years I and
others in this legislature have tried to
address the adequate student aid funding
issue for public education to our
communities and its effect upon the
local education tax rate trying to
attack this problem using our past and
even present Financial technique
approaches has been
frustrating thus in March of 2024 I
contacted the LBA and the Dr for input
on my outof thee boox approaches to
provide enough Revenue to overcome
increased adequate Aid to meet judge
ruoff suggested 7,000 356 Aid figure per
student and also to remove the swep tax
from local taxpayer
bills this bill before you today House
Bill
255 and the next bill on the agenda at 2
p.m. House Bill 318 are two of the four
bills that I had drafted
hopefully to become part of the solution
that addresses the Claremont decisions
and the current legal
situations and as you see the estimated
change in percentage of Revenue that
would be deposited in the education
trust fund from the business profit tax
would be a
43.9% increase bringing in an estimated
addition of $18 plus million to the
education trust fund but a decrease in
the state's operating fund the
legislative intent of this bill and the
next one is of local education property
tax relief for all real estate taxpayers
from family homes small business owners
and the largest companies in the
state and with the conclusion of that Mr
chairman I'll take any
questions long as they're not
Spears well I guess that's going to end
this uh
do I have any questions for
representative
shamberg Aly you look like you might
have a question yeah how are you going
to pay for the rest of the
government first of all I think we
should at least be champions of property
tax
relief and when when it comes to
the approach to operating the rest of
the operating
budget I think we're going to have to
representative Aly
reconstruct
our approach to our social
policies and
to some of
the designated
um designated programs that we have have
out there um it's going to take some
hard work it's going to take as was said
many years ago that there'll be people
that will roll up their sleeves and try
to fix the problem
or there'll be those that will do
whatever it takes uh maybe to shift the
blame somewhere else I'm hoping that
doesn't
occur we have to sit down I I as I said
I presented four bills were drafted
you're seeing in the first
two the first two this for 158 plus the
second one would generated about 68 plus
that's
226 that could be put in the education
trust fund and let the legislature
decide what they'd like to do with that
additional
money uh I don't have any suggestions
even though I mentioned two of them
coming represent
opal just for my knowledge since I'm a
first year member here what was the um
what was the revenue from the interest
in dividends tax in its final
year you Rec call I don't recall is it
there's a representative Ellenberger
might have the
answer oh go ahead it was an excess of
million thank you
okay yes thank you Mr chair why did you
choose that percentage and not some
other different
blend it was a simple just switch first
of all when I went to the LBA and asked
how much would it
take to address the increase in student
aid which is over 500 million and how
much more would it take to
address the swept tax and this was the
simplest process
move just the percentages around it
leaves the option open for the this
committee and for the legislature to
maybe change the percentages if they
would wish I was just trying to generate
some outof the Box thinking on how
to put money into the education trust
fund
representative ORS thank you Mr
chairman thank you representative
shamber for uh entertaining me for a
minute and let me ask you this question
so yeah I don't think there's uh you
know we we want to fund this my my
concern
is there seems to be from what we heard
last week I think it was Drew Klein
testified Josiah Bartlett and uh some of
the stuff I read in this uh New
Hampshire fiscal policy Institute I mean
the revenue goes up in the school
spending you know the spending and the
spending you know so there's there's no
end in the cycle so if you if you have
the solution which you know I know
you're trying to think outside the box
and we got a little time could you go
back to the beginning like in the 1990s
and walk us through this and explain how
how we come out on the right end of this
that was a bit of a joke I just wanted
to see how you would
respond I figured we have a half hour to
kill so no but I do appreciate I do
appreciate your question but
uh I do believe
that this committee here with the next
other two bills that'll be coming in in
the
future can at least address property tax
relief by putting more money in the
education trust fund
and it will allow people in their own
residents in their own Community like
yours to decide how much they want to
put into their local property tax for
education
and if we're giving enough adequate Aid
and we get rid of the swept property tax
portion then I could maybe
agree with
Mr Klein but his was all mostly Theory
not data and I'm trying to present data
numbers that we can look at to
develop a a budget that will cover
our education public
education and reduce our property taxes
and we're just going to have to make
hard choices on the social
programs thank you are you looking to
increase
a different tax or you're just saying we
should make cuts to balance it off I
believe you'll have a bill coming in
502 which will present another source
another bucket of money that would come
into the into
um the education trust fund and the and
the business profits
tax and another bill that has some
suggestions 503 I think which one's 502
is that complete corporate reporting
relative to yes and number 503 is some
changes in four of the bills four of the
revenue sources that I asked the LBA and
the Dr how much they would generate
by a
creative percentage increase
representative duet okay I I got a fish
hook in my lip thank you for taking my
question
um gonna
have take from pet to pay Paul scenario
here $158 million and you've referenced
social programs a couple times can you
more definitively
explain what you mean by that
I think we address various issues here
in the state that are uh for the
citizens of the State uh there's
programs that are out there
that um some people say why do we have
to pay this much or why should the state
be giving this much it'll be some policy
changes to reduce the the amount coming
from the state and maybe be picked up
more by maybe a lot of our nonprofits
which I understand do a great job uh
maybe they will have to increase a
little bit more uh to take on some of
those social issues and fund
them I don't know if that answered your
question no but it was
mle representative elberger thank you Mr
chairman I'm not sure if this question
is properly directed to representative
shamberger somebody else on the
committee actually it's a couple of
questions the State education trust fund
is set at a minimum of 363 million is
that correct when was that
number um
determined represent
Aly
2011 um so in 2011 a number of 363
million was determined
minimum and just an act actual amount so
it can't be higher inflation has
occurred it's down
about that that was my next question
that that in the years from 2011 now to
2025 despite the impact of inflation
that number has remained the
same thank
you representative ORS thank you Mr
chair so one of the problems that I've
run into is that if you want to call
both sides on the issue nobody wants to
you know there's nobody wants a give and
take and uh I've tried to meet with the
school board president where I live
several times and she she won't meet
with me you know she'll say well give me
some days and give me some times and I
do and then we never meet and I I think
the answer is like the schools if you
look look at them there part of the
school has has to be you know they're
educating students but it's also a
business in a sense and you just can't
keep throwing money into a business if
you're not getting an end result that's
a better I mean the
school uh results that I'm reading for
the most part are going down the number
of students are going down but I keep
hearing that all the costs are fixed so
all the costs can't be fixed but I think
there has to be Creative Solutions
number of children in the
classroom uh I hear you know New
Hampshire has 100 plus superintendent we
have one in the Chai Chester I mean you
can just about put all the kids in Chai
Chester in this room I don't know why we
need a superintendent my point is do you
agree that we need to look at some of
the spending in the schools and maybe
find a way to reduce the spending in
order to help balance and work this
thing
through representative ORS I believe
that what I am presenting is property
tax
relief options for both Republicans and
Democrats what you're having a problem
with I think is a local problem of
handling the issue within your
community the community of uh the curge
Regional School District did say that
what was being presented to them when
those 16600 people showed up on
deliberation
day we will pay what is necessary now
there were only 10 some 31 I think that
were not in favor of that approach that
we will pay so I think it's a local on
the spending part it's not something
maybe the state the state should at
least address the clont one and cl on
two decisions and any decision that
comes out of conval regarding Aid and
the other one that regards the
constitutionality of the um swept tax uh
when I was
campaigning seven out of 10 I'd knock on
the
door and I'd ask their opinion what is
most important thing that you think we
could do or what bothers you the most
and it's their property tax MH they're
property tax they didn't say their Town
property they eventually got around to
saying the school property tax and if
you haven't heard that I saw a senator
uh somebody on the other side of the
wall that
said the most important thing I ever
heard was housing well fine maybe he
wasn't in a area that that's all they
were worried about but people are living
in these homes and some of them are
going to start losing their homes unless
this property tax relief comes forth
from
this committee and from the
legislature yes representative
chy thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question in your presentation
are you saying to alleviate the swep tax
or to eliminate the swep
tax I'm saying that if the four bills
that could be part of this solution it
would eliminate the swept tax because
the state would then be able to
adjust its real spending issue it
doesn't it it hasn't it's not spending
the 363 million it is still coming out
of the local property taxpayers pocket
and it's a transfer electronically oh we
got it we'll send it back to them they
don't actually collect it I say
eliminate is what I'm striving
for representa Aly thank you thank you
uh the issue I have with this is that
for
years uh the state has been cutting down
the taxes in the general
fund
and in
response they had to cut down Services
some of these social Services you're
talking about uh and then the towns were
faced with do we use our local property
tax increase our local property tax to
restore these services that we've always
had or the time that the pension fund
was
on uh that they they took away the local
share of the pension fund and the local
groups had to restore the money that the
state had not had to pay anymore the
local groups had to pay it
so isn't doesn't this just move the
money around in another way to the same
conclusion for the property
tax I believe representative Al me
that that is
where some of the structural changes
we'll have to make in our operating
budget are going to have to come
from when local community members as you
know have more money in their pocket
they're not put the property tax uh
taxes they will make more decisions on
what is important in their Community
they'll say what it's properly presented
by the either the school board or a
nonprofit comes in we would like to
see this program go through the town
people will make some decisions
how much they want to put into it but I
do believe that the state has an
obligation to fund those benefits
for police fire
emergency uh I believe the state has
because those individuals those people
are serving serve the entire State they
can go from one Community to another to
help out I think the state should be be
funding that basic principle
not not not all the local communi should
be doing it on their own
no follow
up all right uh representative Murphy
thank you chairman um do you think that
the newly created Committee of
government efficiency may be helpful in
identifying areas for Savings in the
general
fund if they would put representative
Aly on it and
representative M I think that we
may it might be efficient but I
I I don't there is waste there's waste
we waste time in here at times we don't
get started right at 10: because we're
still coming through the door uh we we
we don't get actual questions we get
statements all we do waste time and so
there is waste it's just I think some
people are going to be
targeted by this
new what is it called a committee
a I realize it's called Cod but it's
just
what it might come up with some great
ideas we can all work together that's
probably what we need to do to make this
work yes represent
op thank you Mr chairman um and thank
you representative shamberg for bringing
this because I I I do think it's
important to have this
conversation wherever it leads but but
at least having this conversation to
examine I'd like to follow
up um with a predicate and then a
question following up on something
representative or said um and I do think
that we need to think about public
education
uh and our schools um in economic terms
as well as you know the the general
issue of educating our children but what
we're talking about is creating a
Workforce that will be attractive to
businesses to keep those businesses here
to enable those businesses to continue
to work to continue to innovate um and I
know in my personal case if
committee will forgive me this this
personal detour when my wife and I first
moved to the town of Canaan in
200000 um my wife was pregnant with our
first child and we were working with a
realtor in a community that wasn't
Canaan um and we found a house that we
loved in Canaan and wanted to take a
look at it and the realtor very
specifically said you don't want to go
there the schools aren't
good um
there's story after Story of families
making decisions about where they might
want to move based on the educational
quality in that
District now Hampshire I believe is now
the second has the second oldest
population in the nation we're getting
older um if we want to continue to have
an educated and well-trained
Workforce in that it was it 25 to 50 for
Sweet Spot don't you think we need to
focus on education not just for the
moral and and other social values of
education but also as an economic driver
potentially or the
reverse
representative I believe we should the
state should address it as an economic
driver and uh the US Chamber of Commerce
reinforced the role of the education
system by saying our educational system
is the Cornerstone of an educated
skilled Workforce and our students of
today are tomorrow's Workforce and the
Bia also has stressed they want an
educated
Workforce and they've stressed that
since I saw their last paper was
2011 in
2018 it was also part of their policy to
have an educated Workforce they want
someone to
fund education so that we have an
educated Workforce and we as a state
should be doing
that uh any other questions Mr
chairman seeing none I think because
what I'd like to say as I close is that
the next one at 2:00 yes it's all the
same arguments again so
but I will present
[Laughter]
it all right um thank you very much
thank you Mr
chairman so we have um Dr here
to add their thoughts
CH the chairs this
year good afternoon Mr chair members of
the committee uh we provided you uh with
a a fiscal note quick guide for this
bill as well it's very simple and I
don't have any remarks to add unless
people have questions we just want it to
be available if you needed
us thank you any questions from the
committee
seeing none your fiscal notes were
great anyone else wishing to testify on
HP
255 seeing none I'll will close the
public hearing on HB
255 I guess we get two
minutes
e
e e
okay the time being 2 p.m we're going to
start with our last public session of
today and that would be HB 318 we'll
open the public session on HB
318 and uh we will invite representative
Shamburg back up to
introduce his
Bill thank you Mr chairman what I'll do
is I'll just read the the
title uh representative Tom shamberg
I'll spill 318 and act relative to the
percentage of revenue from business
Enterprise deposited in the education
trust fund and the bill increases the
percentage of revenue from the business
Enterprise tax deposit and education
trust fund which will equal 30
43.9% on the numbers that we've had in
the
past wherever the drra came up with the
am um and the two bills together would
generate an estimated $226 million
that's still
140 million short of reduc or removing
the swep eliminating it all together but
as I said there are two more bills to
come forth in this pack pack that I put
together hopefully uh you will think
about that because it has an estimated
amount of money that might that probably
would cover this and cover some other
things also
so hopefully you had all the questions
uh answered in the last
one I guess my question would be
representative shamber that you know
it's it's I see what you're trying to do
it's admirable to try to fund this to
the extent uh needs to be funded and to
reduce the the Statewide property tax
but the money's got to come from
somewhere so all this now the the the
new shortfall in the general fund um is
going to have to be funded from Sumer
where do you anticipate that coming
from if I may respond Mr chairman since
you mentioned the the
shortfall uh this committee did not
cause that shortfall this committee last
year did not cause that shortfall
they did their due diligence in looking
at all the figures taking the historical
context and emphasized by you Mr
chairman emphasized by representative
ranking member Aly
that there's only so much
money out there to take care of
all this the the these situations and we
are putting in
programs that are causing some of
this deficit that we're seeing now that
we're having to eliminate positions or
not spend
anymore uh but it wasn't caused by this
committee and their approach to how we
should fund I'm not going to say where
that where that decision was made I
think the governor's office May be able
to help us this time since we have a a
governor that U went through the public
education process and understands the
value of education and maybe we would
like to see a solution be
made uh Thinking Out of the Box because
we're not going to get it the other way
we are not going to get it since
1998 representative alme is that
when when a decision was was made we
we'll we'll approach it with a a swept
tax
and take 800 million out of the
operating budget and it's been 40 years
almost or 20
27 years 99
99 still
fighting this
approach this committee could become the
champion of property tax relief at least
getting it out there and let the people
respond
to the legislature on whatever this
committee comes up
with so but the issue would be that now
taxes have to come from somewhere or
programs have to be cut I mean do you
what is your perception of it
that or you're just saying three of
these bills that I have put
together do
not do not
increase the present taxes that are out
there they do not now there is one bill
that's going to come in that you should
find very
interesting but it designates there's
certain things that designates I did go
that's when I saw the LBA I did ask him
how do I
get up to student aid being equal to
$8,000 you student that's the next
that's the next bill yeah are you are
you referring to the bill that increases
the BPT bet brings back the interest in
dividends that bill number 503 I think
okay well that answers then that answers
my question yeah it's there all right
thank you representative
iy representative
shart if you
recall there was a serious property taxx
issue in
Connecticut and Connecticut promised to
get rid of the property
tax if
only an income tax was put
forward and the result was that it
passed and Connecticut got an income
tax and
then it got a sales tax and then the
property tax went up again
and now it's higher than it is just
about anywhere except New Hampshire the
point I'm trying to get at I thought you
were going to ask a question but go
on well give me a chance give me a
chance we already talked earlier about
wasting time by waxing
philosophical the question
is under the structure of New Hampshire
where the towns are in have the ability
to impose a property tax for what the
town wants to do how would it decreasing
the small section such as
swept of that property tax which is
minuscule have anything any bearing
whatsoever on the property tax that as
uh was mentioned in one of the Articles
uh published recently uh less
than 11% of the people in town vote
for how would a state action have
anything to do with what the towns do
and the lack of participation of towns
in their own
government well first of
all the people in the
towns did not vote for a swept tax that
was done by the legislature and if you
use the position of well we were elected
by them so we'll put it on they no
that's
not town of
wilmet by the actions of the state have
to draw 400 and some thousand other
dollars out of their pocket that they
didn't get a chance to vote on swep tax
that is the amount that they have to
come up with that doesn't include the
local property tax which they can vote
on it doesn't
include the
county they send the bill we don't get a
vote on
that local operations operating budget
is decided by the people they control
the money they have been unable to get a
voice what they want to do at the swep
tax that's why we have the lawsuits I
and going back to your income tax and
your sales tax that is not even what I
suggested no no I was and that's why I
say it should be a question versus some
of the statements I don't mean to be
contemptuous I just oh yes
I I just think that it's important that
keep an open mind and let's look at some
solutions and work together on
this okay questions representative
elme thank you this is not directly a
question about uh what you brought
forward but it is something that on Mr
marand is talking about lately which is
that our problem is that we pay a
certain amount per
pupil and we have a lot less pupils than
we used to but we still got our school
buildings and we still got
superintendents in one small spot and
and a lot of other bureaucracy that we
the legislature have told them they have
to have
and have to pay
for so
on his essay on that
was about
why shouldn't we start to think about
what Vermont has been trying to do which
hasn't worked terribly well but to
consolidate
schools and in the North country that's
practically impossible
we talked about that back in
1999 in the committee That was supposed
to be doing school
funding uh and you were going to put a
kid on a bus and have him on the bus for
three hours every day at
least and in other places we tried we
closed two elementary schools since I've
been in Lebanon the Uproar was
incredible but if you don't consolidate
in some ways aren't we just on a losing
track representa B
me where we start a fertility climing
well I used to
teach you may think this is funny all
right but in the town that I lived in
Ohio I was also the mayor but I taught
school and things like that
and we had in one
stretch one decade
a dramatic increase in the number of
pregnancies number of kids and we
finally found out what it was when we
went to clean the water tower we had
pigeons that were getting inside and
whatever they were dropping I think is
caused
that explosion so
uh I can't
answer I thank you Mr chairman I don't
if there's any more questions we were
taking you seriously at first well I'm
glad because the
[Laughter]
people um any other questions yes can I
just make a comment sure oh this is true
I was on the school board in Lexington
Massachusetts and toward the end of the
school year we'd had budget passed and
sometime during the summer and there
were six Elementary schools in one
Elementary School
District three families with
triplets and two families with twins all
of kindergarten age moved into that one
District we had to get another teacher I
mean that wasn't so weird things can
happen but they're not happening here
right
now and you know I don't know for
example how the good people of
Chichester might feel about
consolidating with another District
nearby even if whether the legalities
were there or not and giving up control
over your schools but that may be one of
the things that we do need to look
at those were not children from Orwell
Ohio I guarantee that all right they
didn't go
there okay um I'll get to questions in a
second here but let's I think some of
what we're discussing now is maybe a a
work session type stuff I think we're
we've gone off the the ran for public uh
hearing uh representative
ORS yes so to pick up the conversation a
little bit I mean Chai Chester I think
it'd be a real battle that's what I
don't want to do pick up the
conversation but no but I mean I guess
the question I'd ask you is do you think
there's the possibility that some of us
could get together and sit down I mean
most
businesses have to look in word first
when things are going wrong right so
have you ever heard of the gold in the
mind
concept no okay so basically the gold in
the mind concept is if you need to cut
your
expenses this isn't a water tower
joke you know you have to look at what
you're doing right so when I work uh
with dold in a tank manufacturer uh a
facility you all heard of them BAE
Systems what they were doing is is uh
they were they're having problems in the
Manu in the in the manufacturing process
and a lot of it came as a result of
improper drill sharpening so they're
drilling holes with improperly sharpened
drill bits and it's and it was causing a
lot of product waste because the holes
were either slightly elongated or
whatever it might be they didn't meet
spec so the the whole thought is to look
Inward and start looking at where you
can save I and I know in chiester we
have some pretty small
classrooms we have two adults I think in
every classroom and you know so there's
there's money we could
save thank you and and that's responding
to his well let me just let me just um
educate the committee I mean something
like that or some of the other things
that have been said are would you
believe questions because um but okay
answer that and to answer that we should
look our St legislature should look at
what it has made education do by
unfunded mandates 118 of them that this
state has
required where are we going to find that
we
can't go out and raise our prices on
things like businesses can so thank you
Mr
chairman thank you I'm seeing no more
questions okay I have the uh Dr once
again for this
Bill good afternoon members of the
committee I'm for the record my name is
Lauren O Sullivan and I'm the senior
Financial Analyst at the Department of
Revenue and earlier today we did provide
a fiscal note quick guide that
essentially reiterates the fiscal note
that is um attached to the bill and we
don't have necessarily any further
comment but we are here to answer any
questions as it relates to um the
implementation of this uh Bill thank you
do we have any questions on the
implementation of this bill
or numbers it may
affect seeing none thank you for being
here have a good
day is there anyone else who would like
to testify on HB 318
seeing none I'll close the public
hearing on HB
318 okay that concludes today's
business
um so as I said earlier next week we'll
meet on Monday and Tuesday so one thing
that I've um actually I think I already
announced it but I'll just say it again
um so we're going to hear from agencies
from roughly 10 to three on Monday and
then um and you should all have it in
your email by now we're going to ex
three bills um on Monday so anyone who's
bringing amendments to those three bills
they are HB
328 HB 163 and HB 83 if you're bringing
any amendments to those please have them
ready for Monday so we can exec those
bills and they'll be as I said exec at 3
so you know if there needs to be some
clean up during the day or whatever it'
be nice if you had them ready by
beginning of the day but it gives a
little bit of leeway so and any
questions from
anybody seeing none thank you close the
meeting e